[Musique]
14h sur public sénat bonjour à tous
nouvelle émission des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement soyez les
bienvenus dans une heure vous connaissez
le principe les sénateurs vont
interpeller le gouvernement sur les
sujets chauds du moment tout le monde
est en place regardez cette belle
brochette qu'on a deux journalistes
aujourd'hui aux rêves états et dans
l'hémicycle audrey bonjour sur quoi le
gouvernement va devoir rendre des
comptes aujourd'hui et bien avant toute
réponse il sera question ici au sénat
d'un hommage extrêmement solennelle
rendus au caporal-chef maxime blasco
décédé vendredi dernier en opérations au
mali après ce moment de recueillement
le gouvernement sera interrogé sur la
hausse des énergies le gaz et
l'électricité
que peut faire le gouvernement pour
aider les ménages français c'est la
question à laquelle il devra répondre
tout à l'heure merci beaucoup et audrey
on ne présente plus quand un calme et
quentin qui est en salle des conférences
quand un bon jour vous allez interroger
ministre et sénateur donnez nous le
programme on va revenir notamment sur la
tension et qui est montée d'un cran hier
entre le garde des sceaux et szczesny
bas à l'occasion du début de l'examen du
projet de loi dit de confiance en la
justice ça tombe bien ce que philippe
balland à répondre à nos questions ici
en salle des conférences très très bien
jean m'assieds streamer politique sur la
plateforme switch est avec nous bonjour
jean quels sont les grands sujets qui
intéressent les internautes aujourd'hui
bonjour steve et bien écoute on va
suivre ensemble la séance des questions
au gouvernement avec les internautes et
on attend notamment les questions des
sénateurs et des sénatrices sur
l'augmentation du prix du gaz a tout à
leur genre programme de cette première
heure cette question comment renouer la
confiance des citoyens envers la justice
la moitié des français disent ne pas se
fier à cette institution pourtant
central de notre république pour
recoller les morceaux le gouvernement un
plan il a présenté une loi au parlement
elle est arrivée hier au sénat suffisant
pas suffisant efficace plus efficace on
en débat à 14h30 avec agnès canayer
sénatrice les républicains de la
seine-maritime et cécile kerman
sénatrice commune c'était de la loire
mais d'abord attention ça flanc mais ça
va pas s'arrêter tout de suite les prix
de l'énergie non finissent plus de
grimper prochaine augmentation le tarif
du gaz plus 12% à partir de ce vendredi
alors comment expliquer c'est aussi
surtout comment faire baisser la facture
on en parle dans un instant avec mes
invités mais avant ça on fait le point
avec pierre henri old boys
les prix de l'énergie s'affolent le
régulateur angie annonce une
augmentation de 12,6 pour cent du prix
du gaz au 1er octobre une hausse qui
s'ajoute à celle de cette année + 10 %
en juillet +5 % en août et plus 8,7 pour
cent en septembre
du côté de l'électricité ufc que choisir
prévoit une hausse de 10% janvier
prochain soit en moyenne 150 euros de
plus par an et qui avait déjà été
augmenté de 1,6 pour cent en février
dernier face à l'emballement des prix le
gouvernement sur le chèque j'ai annoncé
il ya quelques semaines pour prendre
effet en décembre un chèque énergie
exceptionnelle s'ajoutant à celui que
nous avions créé qui sera versé en
janvier après la crise et gilet jaune
s'ajoutant donc à ce chèque une
bonification de 100 euros qui va
concerner plus de 6 millions de nos
concitoyens
mais vous avez raison
cela ne suffit pas une aide
exceptionnelle qui s'ajoute au chèque de
150 euros versée au printemps dernier et
qui sera renouvelé en 2022 depuis
plusieurs mois les français ont
également vu les prix grimper dans les
stations service avec plus de 13% pour
le gazole et +15 % pour le sans plomb 95
pour pallier la flambée des prix le
gouvernement annonce travailler sur des
mesures supplémentaires qui seront
annoncées dans les prochains jours
comment faire baisser la facture on en
parle avec prisca thévenot bonjour vous
êtes porte-parole la république en
marche conseillère régionale d'île de
france merci d'être avec nous benjamin
coriat est aussi avec nouveau jour vous
êtes économiste membre des économistes
atterrés auteur du livre le un commun le
climat et le marché ça apparaît à
l'écran et ça paraît aux éditions les
liens qui libèrent laurent duplomb
bonjour selon josette sénateurs les
républicains de la haute loire
secrétaire de la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat merci d'être avec
nous pour commencer on va essayer de
comprendre un peu ce qui se passe je me
tourne vers vous jama coria pourquoi
cette hausse des prix bah écoutez il ya
des éléments va dire conjoncturelle qui
sont extrêmement forts
bombe à la reprise a fait que en
particulier en asie parce que vide voilà
il ya une très forte demande et que les
méthaniers vont plutôt de ce côté là il
ya une baisse en tout cas une stabilité
alors que on a une augmentation de la
demande
du gaz russe probablement aussi pour des
raisons un peu stratégique impasse que
par derrière il ya les négociations sur
le 'pipeline' qui doit passer par
l'europe du nord donc c'est sans doute
une petite pression sur l'allemagne bon
bref il ya une série d'éléments
la reprise elle même un proprement dite
posco vide qui évidemment est forte et
puis peut-être anticipé ce problème tout
est fait il s'agissait d' anticiper
alors oui on concède qu'à une hausse à
ces mêmes vous comme on l'avait dit une
flambée de l'énergie mais ça a été
anticipé notamment avec la mise en place
du chèque énergie au lendemain des gilet
jaune une mise en place exceptionnelle
une complémentaire de 100 euros qui va
être versée à plus de 6 millions va
venir mais france n'a jamais parlé du
rôle de la russie notamment dans cette
augmentation des prix est-ce qu' il
n'aurait pas fallu peut-être discuter
avec la russie avant est-ce qu'il faut
pas maintenant s'engager dans des
discussions avec la russie oui en fait
une fois qu'on a compté ça bien sûr que
les gars les discussions peuvent avoir
lieu c'est d'un sujet géopolitique comme
vous venez très justement de le dire
mais il n'empêche que force est de
constater que les prix augmentent et
flambe donc il faut aussi des réponses
immédiates aux français donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut regarder tout ce sujet
dans une temps polaire temporalité bien
précises première chose des mesures
d'urgence répondre tout de suite donc le
chèque énergie mais également à prime
rénove parce que il s'agit de faire
baisser la pression du coût de l'énergie
dans l'île dans chez les ménages mais
également de permettre de moins
consommer en tout cas de consommer avec
des sujets environnementaux ses 105 500
mille foyers qui ont demandé ça mais
après il ya aussi de façon plus
structurelle et plus long terme entre
guillemets sur le marché de l'énergie
lui même et ça c'est bruno le maire qui
l'a annoncé parce qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le prix de l'électricité
est lié étroitement au prix du jeu au
prix du gaz or l'électricité et vient
essentiellement retard de 110% du
nucléaire en france on va reparler dans
quelques instants mais le laurent
duplomb à ce que pour expliquer comment
ça se traduit comment cette pause se
traduit dans votre département par
exemple ce que vous avez pu parler avec
vos administrés de toute façon dans mon
département c'est comme dans tous les
départements peut-être même un peu plus
puisque on est un département de
montagne qui demande souvent en hiver
d'être plus chauffer que dans un
département de plaine ou dans un
département proches de la méditerranée
ou de l'océan je pense que la réalité de
ce problème là il est aussi n'at on le
fait qu'on n'a pas su véritablement
appréhender l'évolution de la
consommation d énergie et que notre pays
parce que on n'a pas le courage
européens sont affichés en a souvent des
injonctions qui sont complètement
contradictoire on veut passer la voiture
à l'électricité on ne pourrait gones on
ne trouve pas les solutions pour
produire l'électricité on ferme les
centrales nucléaires mais on ne donne
pas les moyens de faire plus
d'électricité renouvelable on a des
dogmes d'un autre pays qui est que ce
soit le gouvernement actuel ou même
auparavant sur par exemple l'énergie on
pourrait se servir du nombre de fleuves
que nous avons pour faire livrer
l'électricité aujourd'hui
l'hydroélectricité vous avez une
proposition de loi qui a été votée et
présenté par daniel grémillet qui est
bien plus spécialistes comme moi sur
l'énergie qui n'a pas prospéré parce que
tout simplement dogmatiquement on ne
veut pas parler de l'hydroélectricité
alors qu'on ait atteint pays qui
pourraient véritablement produire
beaucoup plus d'énergie et que la réelle
tout cela elle est un peu la réalité de
notre économie en règle générale c'est
que ne prévoyant pas et bien ce qu'il
arrive aujourd'hui sur l'attention du
marché fait part des continents qui
consomment et qui ont peut être plus de
moyens pour payer fait qu'aujourd'hui et
bien la france se trouve dans une
situation difficile faut quand même pas
oublier alors il ya des spécialistes
qu'il irait peut-être mieux que moi ou
qui meurent prendront si je dis une
bêtise mais au niveau énergétique
on est sur plusieurs années sur un
risque de black out énergétique pendant
l'hiver dû à la ferme de fès à la
fermeture de fessenheim est un nom
réflexion de la modernisation de notre
parc de production électrique qui peut
nous faire courir des risques en cas de
de climat plutôt négatif du moins de
baisse de température qui demanderait
trop consommer plus d'énergie et qui
pourrait nous conduire dans une
situation de black out et donc de
l'impossibilité de fournir votre quand
même impressionnant à laurent duplomb
bon déjà il faut rappeler que le sujet
dont on parle effectivement un effet
extrêmement important mais qu'il n'est
malheureusement pas entre guillemets
franco français on y touche tous les
pays on touche tous les pays européens
donc je veux bien loin en face un sujet
politique mais là je pense qu'il faut
surtout en faire un sujet technique et
devrait pourtant voir le berger je vous
ai je vous ai je vous ai patiemment
écouté je pense que ça sera
donc le sujet vraiment l'hydraulique oui
vous avez raison il faut diversifier
notre notre portefeuille et c'est bien
ce qui est fait et ça se fait pas en
deux minutes séparent en deux ans ça se
fait sur le long terme parce que au
sujet de l'énergie se passe aussi le
sujet de la préservation de
l'environnement et la sauvegarde de
l'environnement donc oui il faut un mix
eunuques c'est un mix énergétique et le
terme est bien là avec une part de
nucléaire extrêmement importante non
négligeable mais également des énergies
renouvelables et l'hydraulique
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est
peut-être pas assez mais ça représente
quand même 10 % de la production donc
oui il faut continuer à se développer
mais je pense que sur ce sujet là il
faut sortir des querelles partisanes et
regarder concrètement ce qu'il faut
encore une fois le sujet et européens
parce que ça s'en va du fonctionnement
du marché et ça on va surtout de la
construction du prix est ce que c'est
une bombe sociale est ce que vous
redoutez un mouvement type gilles jaune
plus que de redouter en fait les plaies
et politiques cubains coup dur pour bien
sûr exactement les politiques publiques
sont là pour répondre à un besoin à une
demande à une urgence et cette urgence
effectivement elle est de l'ordre très
concrète du pouvoir d'achat des français
qui a bien évidemment pu être augmentés
avec différentes mesures sociales qui
ont été mises en place par le
gouvernement je vais pas y revenir mais
la taxe d'habitation par exemple mais
effectivement quand on voit que de
l'autre côté des des coûts enfin des
coûts structurels eux continuent à
augmenter il faut agir donc oui c'est
pour ça que le chèque énergie a été mis
en place
qu'il a été revalorisé cette année mais
ça ne peut pas être une éternelle
solution il faut travailler d'état sont
suffisantes pages à ma carrière si je
m'accrochais excusez moi c'est un
phénomène qui est durable selon vous
cette hausse des prix de l'énergie au en
tout cas pour 2022 certainement au delà
c'est très difficile de faire des
prévisions mais oui il faut s'attendre à
ce que ça soit durable il est en tout
cas ça dure c'est quelle échelle rob a
cessé sur la décennie ce qu'il ya à voir
qu'on est sur des risques de black out
ça existe et surtout ce qui est
extrêmement préoccupant c'est que on est
sujet à des fluctuations du type de
celle qu'on vient d'avoir maintenant
qu'ils peuvent se reproduire à n'importe
quel moment je veux dire c'est un peu
les lois du marché alors on a parlé de
l'hydraulique etc oui c'est vrai que
yahia il ya une action parce que la
vraie question c'est ça va se reproduire
tout ça donc la vraie question c'est
comment se prépare l'examen et comment
on prépare l'avenir la corse ça va pas
se faire en cinq minutes un mois je suis
je suis jour là peut-être qu'on a
peut-être trouvé le coupable je vais
vous faire écouter jodry gilles lemaire
oui
formation
le diagnostic est extrêmement clair le
marché unique de l'électricité est
aberrant et obsolète ecoutez-le s'était
d'entrée notre nouvelle émission extra
locales sur public sénat le marché
unique européen de l'électricité ne
marche pas il est aberrant nous en
france on s'approvisionne en électricité
à partir des centrales nucléaires et de
l'énergie hydraulique donc on a une
énergie qui est décarbonée
très bas mais le marché unique de
l'électricité européen fait qu'il ya un
alignement des prix de l'électricité en
france sur les prix du gaz donc on prend
de plein fouet cette augmentation des
prix du gaz alors même qu'on a notre
indépendance en matière de production
électrique c'est totalement aberrant le
marché unique de l'électricité
fonctionne suivant des règles qui sont
obsolètes il faut revoir de fond en
comble le fonctionnement de ce marché
unique de l'électricité
benjamin coriat la faute à l'europe pour
partie oui pour partie oui c'est à dire
que la manière dont les prix sont
régulés en europe en établissant des
liens entre le prix du gaz le plus
d'électricité et ce terrain oui donc sur
ce point le ministre a tout à fait
raison et les choses doivent être revues
bon donc il ya une action à mener de ce
côté là mais ce sur quoi je voulais
assister c'est que s'il faut pas
seulement penser en termes de
l'augmentation de l'offre électrique
vers l'hydraulique etc il faut aussi
penser en termes de consommation et de
sécurisation de nos besoins et de baisse
de nos besoins décédé deux ans et ce
coût mais bien entendu mais bien entendu
alors de ce point de vue quand autant
j'admets que le problème ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui et que voilà c'est vrai
que ça serait pas juste de dire ah ben
voilà c'est la faute du gouvernement
c'est bien plus complexe autant il ya
des responsabilités qui doivent être
prises ça veut dire que par exemple les
propositions qui sont faites et depuis
longtemps de mettre fin aux passoires
thermiques parce que ça touche les plus
pauvres et sa touche une consommation
d'énergie complètement folle et ben très
peu de suite ils ont été données la
proposition qu'avait fait la convention
citoyenne climat était absolument car et
il n'y avait plus qu'à la suivre elle a
été totalement à dieu corée est
totalement effacés de la même manière
plus généralement la rénovation
thermique la protection thermique de
l'habitat bien sûr il ya la prime rénove
mais si on prend sur les trois ou quatre
dernières années parce qu'il faut aussi
parler quand même de deux 2 2 de ce qui
a été fait dans la période récente même
si tout se résume pas la période récente
ça c'est bien clair
comment dire la quantité de logements
qui ont été rénovés par rapport à ceux
qui auraient étaient nécessaires et
dérisoire donc je veux dire c'est bien
de montrer l'europe du doigt et en
l'occurrence c'est juste de montrer
leurs robes du doigt mais il faut
regarder aussi devant sa porte et il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on aurait pu faire
qui n'ont pas été faites alors quelles
sont les solutions qui vont peut-être
c'est ce que parce qu'elle sur les
passoires thermiques
c'est pas demain qu'on va les résoudre
avec les mesures qui ont été prises dans
le cas de la loi et lorsque l'image
justement partie du combat justement par
les six prévenus les actes et totalement
la situation la solution actuelle du
gouvernement pour lutter contre cette
hausse des prix elle s'appelle le chèque
énergie vous en avait parlé il ya
quelques instants 6 millions de foyers
qui vont recevoir un chèque de 100 euros
au mois de décembre on va retrouver
quand un calme mais quentin qui est avec
une spécialiste des questions de
précarité au sénat la socialiste annie
le houérou oui annie le houérou bonjour
vous étiez la présidente jusqu'à il ya
quinze jours de la mission d'information
précarisation et paupérisation du sénat
dans ce rapport vous revenez notamment
sur la précarité énergétique
vous parlez de 3,5 millions de ménages
qui seraient concernés vous dites le
coût de la facture d'énergie est une
préoccupation pour 70 à 80% des français
dans ce contexte qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette hausse des tarifs
réglementés du gaz pour trois millions
de français ça va être encore plus
compliqué pour tous et précaires
énergétiques ça va être très très
compliqué sachant que les dépenses
contraintes d'un mine d'un ménage pauvre
donc en bas de l'échelle des revenus
représentent le logement et l'énergie
représentent une part très importante
donc bien évidemment ces mesures vont
impacter de manière très difficile la
vie des des français dans ces situations
dans votre rapport vous dites que la
moitié des français 10 mythe et le
chauffage pour maîtriser leurs factures
et 12 à 15% sont véritablement en
situation de précarité parlez nous de la
situation de ces précaires et bien
l'hiver arrivant les factures
d'électricité de gaz augmentant nous
connaissons énormément de familles qui
sont dans l'obligation en fait de
réduire ses charges et donc réduisent le
chauffage donc ça n'est pas bon pour la
famille ce n'est pas bon pour la santé
et je pense que là nous avons une
politique volontariste mais vraiment
volontarisme de transition énergétique
qui va associer aussi les besoins de
notre économie la transition écologique
et puis le revenu des familles donc il
faut impérativement qu'il y ait un grand
plan national de d'économie d'énergie et
de rénovation de nos logements y compris
le logement social qui a été
malheureusement mis en difficulté lors
de ce quinquennat avec une baisse de la
capacité d'investissement de ceux de ses
partenaires du logement social et bien
nos familles peuvent très directement
voir l'impact en fait de ces politiques
en ayant des factures d'électricité et
d'énergie réduite réduite oui on
entendait le constat structurelles sur
l'isolation des logements dans ce
contexte que penser de ces chèques
énergie adressé à 6 millions de foyers
modestes 200 euros sept jeux quoi c'est
un pansement sur une jambe de bois
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est un
plus c'est quelque chose que nous avons
partagé avec la rapporteur de ce rapport
mais ça ne règle pas le problème je
crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'il y ait
une politique plus structurantes qui
vraiment
revoir
les qualités de logements et en
particulier les logements sociaux le
chèque énergie est un plus bien
évidemment mais il ne repense pas le les
modalités en fait et les dépenses
incontournables d'une famille plus à
dépenses sont incontournables et bien
évidemment plus la marge et le bien-être
de des familles s'en voit
pas quitter un terrain très dernier mot
très rapide mais la baisse de la tva sur
ses dépenses d'énergie c'est une
solution que vous avez étudié qui est
possible alors proposé par certains
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
nous n'avons pas étudié cette baisse de
tva je pense qu'il faut regarder de près
mais moi je suis convaincu qu'il ne faut
pas faire une baisse de tva linéaire
pour l'ensemble des français puisque
nous voyons la politique fiscale qui a
été menée pendant ce quinquennat a
permis à certaines
catégories sociales de faire aussi
beaucoup d'économies
sur les impôts or nous voyons qu'il y a
ce 5 % des français les plus riches qui
ont bénéficié de cette fiscalité
favorable donc je pense qu'il faut avoir
une politique beaucoup plus ciblées
c'est blé sur les dépenses
incontournables celles qui permettent à
nos habitants de se loger de se nourrir
et puis de se déplacer aussi parce que
le déplacement c'est aller au travail
c'est aussi ce sont aussi des coups
merci beaucoup et donc annie le houérou
je renvoie à votre rapport 1 qui est
paru mi-septembre sur la précarité et la
pauvreté en france un bris skate est
venu le chèque énergie ça suffit pas
c'est ce qu'on nous dit non en fait ce
qu'on dit et là pourrait même chose en
fait il ya différents bien mais pas
suffisant mais oui en fait le chèque
énergie est là pour répondre à une
urgence à l'immédiateté du moment des
foyers français évidemment un plus de 6
millions de foyers modestes
ensuite il ya effectivement le deuxième
aspect qui est effectivement travailler
notre consommation d'énergie nous devons
le faire notamment pour notre facture
d'électricité mais également pour
l'environnement et là ça va dans l'objet
de la loi climat et résidences avec la
prime rénove qui était mis en place mais
également la primeur et notre entente
est de l'imprimé la neuve c'est pour
lutter contre les passoires énergétiques
et donc de permettre à chaque foyer qui
le souhaitent d'avoir jusqu'à 20000
euros de subventions pour pouvoir mettre
son logement conformité mais également
de mettre la pression parce qu'il faut
en parler sur les propriétaires qui
louent des logements et notamment en
gelant leurs prix de loyer
d'augmentation de loyer et puis ensuite
on en a parlé juste avant donc je vais
pas y revenir plus longtemps mais c'est
revoir le fonctionnement du marché
européen de l'énergie moi je vais
revenir sur le dernier point qui a été
souligné par à madame la sénatrice sur
le sujet de la taxe effectivement pour
réduire de façon très simple besson les
taxes besson la tva parce que du coup ça
va avoir une solution en gros il faut
aussi comprendre comment fonctionne le
prix de l'énergie le prix de l'énergie
c'est un tiers un tiers un tiers grosso
modo c'est un tiers pour le fournisseur
un tiers pour la distribution et un
tiers des taxes mais les taxes c'est
principalement est majoritairement la
csp et la cspc quoi mais il faut nous
éclaire mais voilà ça permet de financer
d'aidé au développement d j
renouvelables donc je trouves tu veux
faire attention aux fausses bonnes idées
qui à priori font plutôt un peu souffler
que de réelles solutions laurent duplomb
sur les solutions du gouvernement pour
lutter contre cette hausse des tarifs je
pense que déjà dans un premier temps il
faut qu'on se pose la problématique de
produire l'électricité ou de produire
l'énergie parce que être tributaire des
autres c'est ne pas maîtriser le coût
qui correspond à cette énergie en
matière d quand on regarde aujourd'hui
les cotes et quand on regarde
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe il faudrait
que nous que nous créions toutes les
années une centrale nucléaire pendant
dix ans pour répondre à l'évolution de
la demande énergétique vous avez vous eu
est de savoir à bout c'est une pierre je
sais vous pourquoi pas on l'a fait
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ces énergies une
énergie décarbonée je pense que la
problématique elle est là elle est
qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas où on veut
aller on veut faire les énergies
renouvelables mais chaque fois qu'on met
des éoliennes à chaque fois qu'on met
autre chose ça ne va pas on veut faire
de la méthanisation on a toutes les
associations du monde qui remonte au
créneau parce qu'on trouve que la
médiation ça fait pas on veut plus de
centrales nucléaires on veut pas de
barrages hydroélectriques et pourtant la
seule solution qu'on a à mon avis c'est
de traiter le problème de l'offre et de
la demande si on a une offre suffisante
on sera moins tributaires des autres et
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est obligé
d'acheter une part de notre énergie et
dieu sait qu'elle est importante parce
que le pétrole et ainsi de suite on fait
aussi partie eh bien on est tributaire
de l'évolution non seulement des marchés
mais en plus de l'évolution de la
spéculation sur les marchés vous êtes
une baisse des taxes par exemple vous
moi je sais pas s'il faut une baisse des
taxes je pense qu'il faut réfléchir un
pour un programme global qui ne consiste
pas à boucher les trous à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème par de l'argent
public et déversé auprès des populations
l'argent que va coûter cette mesure
annoncée elle ne permettra pas par
l'investissement à traiter le problème
dans les mois ou dans les années futures
c'est un coup d'éléments qui va
permettre de faire accepter un peu plus
à la population la augmentation mais ça
traite pas le problème est que je pense
que notre souci comme sur plein d'autres
c'est qu'on ne peut pas se poser sur un
débat objectif sur ces problématiques là
et donc n'ayant pas de plan n'y a pas
véritablement une volonté de recréer ce
qui a été fait dans certaines
concernaient ya encore quelques
décennies 2 à produire de l'électricité
ou de l'énergie eh bien on se retrouve
bloquée dans des discours impossible je
me permets juste de réagir sur un point
où klaus grosso modo à bien sûr aller
j'aimerais écouter jean marc coma sur
l'énergie effectivement il faut quelque
part excusez moi du terme il faut faire
un peu dur en même temps il faut aller
sur le nucléaire et
renouvelables par contre monsieur le
sénateur permettez moi de vous dire que
100 euros à la fin du mois pour des
ménages qui vont avoir des difficultés
pour boucler leurs fins de mois c'est
pas anodin 100 euros ne serait-ce que 16
euro d'augmenter en train de montrer
qu'on est obligé de le faire si on
n'était pas tributaire d'une
augmentation de 10 ans on avait fait
plein de choses à pâques 10 ans mais
bien sûr évidemment 100 euros
surtout pour les ménages à faible revenu
c'est pas négligeable mais c'est à peu
près un quart de ce que va leur coûter
l'augmentation éléments de 2 des prix de
l'électricité donc on est vraiment très
loin du compte on est très loin du
compte alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
ce l'on vient on parle même pas la
compétitivité des entreprises avec st et
alors
les entreprises encore une fois il faut
toujours distinguer les deux questions
il ya la question de la de immédiate
ainsi je peux dire comment on fait
comment vient en aide à tous ces gens
qui peuvent pas se chauffer comment ce
que les français c'est ça qui est en
train de se passer et qui va se passer
encore davantage bon alors la formule
cheikh pourquoi pas mais il faut qu'il
soit beaucoup plus substantiel et dans
ce cas là il faut qu'il soit aussi
différencier si vous êtes pour le
blocage des prix de l'énergie vous par
exemple écoutez je sais pas si je suis
pour le blocage du prix de l'énergie
mais je suis certainement pour que les
français puissent se chauffer donc que
quel que soit le moyen il faut
il faut il parvenir et la question de la
différenciation des effets est
importante parce qu'il y en a qui
peuvent supporter ces 400 euros et y en
a qui peuvent absolument pas donc ça
c'est la première chose ensuite
deuxièmement sur le fond moi je suis
d'accord avec ça c'est à dire que il ya
vraiment un problème de choix
stratégique vers où on veut aller non
alors qu'il y ait besoin de me c'est les
ressources en énergie c'est certain
c'est certain personne va dire qu'il
faut que du nucléaire ou qu'il faut que
du renouvelable mais c'est vrai que on a
vraiment l'impression que on n'y a pas
dit y'a pas de choix qui a véritablement
fait tu veux dire sur le nucléaire par
exemple moi j'ai beaucoup de réserve pas
du tout pour des raisons de carbone
évidemment mais pour des raisons qu'on
connaît il y avait plus personne qui
veut enfouir des déchets c'est la croix
et la bannière pour trouver un lieu pour
offrir des déchets ça veut dire quelque
chose quand même un de la confiance des
français vis-à-vis de cette filière mais
je rajoute encore une chose la dernière
cela centrale de dernière génération on
en est à 17 milliards de dépassement
vous vous rendez compte ce qu'on peut
faire avec 17 milliards par exemple pour
des énergies vertes bon donc je veux
dire un moment il faut faire les comptes
à un moment il faut faire les comptes et
c'est vrai que comment dire donner une
orientation claire mais claire y compris
aux entreprises pour qui ça sera
peut-être difficile mais qui au moins
sont ou ont va parce que pendant elles
savent pas où on va avec un peu de
lobbying elles obtiennent qu'on revienne
sur des mesures
c'est pas sympa à voir avec l'énergie
mais ça pourrait le glyphosate par
exemple c'est ces caractéristiques ont
dit voilà ça le sujet petit lobbying non
non ça va on vous donne encore deux ans
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
donc je veux dire il faut avoir une
politique extrêmement ferme extrêmement
clair au moins sur deux points qui sont
ceux qu'on a ce qu'on vient de voir sur
les questions de la précarité
énergétique etc et il faut pas jouer
comme on a fait avec la proposition de
la convention citoyenne en lit du coran
complètement en renvoyant les délais en
laissant les propriétaires continuer à
louer des choses qui sont un louable ah
bon et sur la mobilité c'est les grands
domaines voilà et donc c'est vrai que de
ce point de vue les indications qui sont
données ne sont pas claires 1 j'aimerais
entendre prisca c'est venu parce qu'on
arrive au terme de ce débat
malheureusement est-ce que selon vous le
thème principal de l'élection
présidentielle va porter sur le pouvoir
d'achat ou sur l'immigration lequel
selon vous mais en fait ce qui est bien
c'est que ça va pouvoir porter sur
plusieurs thématiques et ça serait bien
que ça arrive dans le débat
effectivement il ya effectivement le
sujet de l'immigration de la sécurité si
le sujet du pouvoir d'achat et comme on
vient de le dire mais vous souhaitez
porter le débat sur fois sur le pouvoir
d'achat ou sur l'immensité vous savez je
vais apprendre sa personne ce ne sont
pas les politiques qui décident des
thèmes des campagnes présidentielles
mais ce sont bien les français mais
orienté oui mais sont quand même les
français et donc effectivement il y aura
le sujet du pouvoir d'achat mais y aura
aussi le sujet de l'environnement qui
est extrêmement important le sujet du
droit des femmes et le sujet
effectivement de l'immigration sur ce
sujet laurent duplomb sur le sujet du
thème lequel doit porter cette élection
présidentielle qui arrive dans le sujet
principal du thème de qu'est-ce qui
devrait être portée c'est la
compétitivité de la france et sa
capacité à continuer de produire
aujourd'hui quand on voit comment que ça
se passe je ne suis pas beaucoup joué je
ne suis pas politique puisque je suis je
suis professeur et chercheur mais
j'aimerais beaucoup quand même je
souhaite que un des thèmes centraux
parce que y'en a plusieurs il est normal
que les français débattre de plusieurs
thèmes soit le changement climatique et
la transition écologique parce que je
veux dire ce qu'on est en train de vivre
est absolument catastrophique donc je
veux dire il est vraiment plus que temps
qui est une délibération collective et
qui est des choix collectifs qu'il soit
fait merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat il
est 14h28 les questions d'actualité vont
débuter dans un peu plus de trente
minutes tout le monde est sur le pont
vous voyez à l'écran quand un calme est
en salle des conférences gens m'a scié
et sur tweets chez audrey vous états est
au coeur de la machine elle est dans
l'hémicycle audrey sur quoi les
sénateurs vont interpeller le
gouvernement avant de poser toute
question les sénateurs rendront un
hommage solennel au caporal-chef maxime
blasco le militaire de 34 ans tuée
vendredi dernier en opérations au mali
l'opération barkan dans laquelle il
était engagé devrait être au coeur des
échanges cet après midi la ministre des
armées florence parly devra répondre sur
la forme que prendra cette opération à
l'avenir emmanuel macron a annoncé en
juin dernier la fin de barkan dont la
forme dans laquelle on la connaît et
puis l'autre grand thème aujourd'hui
c'est le pouvoir d'achat des français a
vous en avez parlé l'augmentation des
énergies que peut faire le gouvernement
pour aider les français les ménages
français ça quand ça concerne beaucoup
un les sénateurs la première question
posée tout à l'heure au gouvernement par
le socialiste joël bigot sera sur ce
sujet et puis il ya cette image qui a
beaucoup choqué la construction d'un mur
entre paris et la seine saint denis pour
bloquer d'une centaine de consommateurs
de crack le mur de la honte pour les
élus gérald darmanin sera interpellé sur
le sujet merci beaucoup audrey à tout à
l'heure on passe au second thème de
cette émission à présent comment
rétablir la confiance des citoyens
envers la justice plus de la moitié la
moitié des français ne font plus
confiance dans cette institution
centrale de notre république pour
renverser la vapeur le gouvernement un
plan il est actuellement étudiée par le
sénat regarder ce sujet les signé sandra
cerqueira
remplacer le rappel à la loi par un
avertissement pénale probatoire ce
nouveau dispositif sera effectif le 1er
janvier 2023 et doit venir sanctionner
les petits délits près de 270 milles
rappel à la loi sont prononcés chaque
année ils ne font office d'aucune
condamnation et d'aucune mention au
casier judiciaire
une mesure obsolète trop faible pour
être efficace selon le garde des sceaux
cet avertissement vise donc à durcir la
réponse pénale cette alternative aux
poursuites
étaient devenues incompréhensibles pour
nos concitoyens un cycle pour les forces
de l'ordre qui la mettait en oeuvre pire
que cela elle portait gravement atteinte
à l'autorité de l'état la solennité de
cette nouvelle réponse pénale sera
renforcée car seul un procureur ou son
délégué pour un l'a prononcée en cas de
récidive durant cette période probatoire
les personnes mises en cause sous
surveillance seront alors jugés pour les
deux délits le nouveau et l'ancien le
sénat a validé le dispositif mais a tenu
à prolonger la période probatoire à
trois ans pour donner à cette mesure une
portée plus forte le intérêt de
l'avertissement pénale probatoire c'est
de dire à l'intéressé vous avez commis
des faits
vous faites l'objet d'un avertissement
préalable si vous commettez de nouveau
c'est fait vous serez jugés pour les
nouveaux faits et les anciens la
proposition du sénat c'est de prolonger
d'un an à trois ans la durée de cette
épée de damoclès placée sur la tête d'un
primo délinquants c'est donc une
recherche de plus grande efficacité de
cet avertissement probatoire
les officiers de police judiciaire
jusque là en charge des rappels à la loi
salut la fin du dispositif inefficace
selon eux pour lutter contre la petite
délinquance et pour en débattre j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
agnès canayer bonjour bonjour sénatrice
les républicains de seine maritime
rapporteur du texte justement confiance
dans la justice merci d'être avec nous
en face de vous si circulent kerman
bonjour jadis communiste de la loire et
vice président de la commission des lois
le remplacement donc on l'a entendue
dans ce sujet le remplacement du rappel
à la loi par un avertissement pénale
probatoire c'est efficace selon vos
agnès canayer bah écoute et on l'espère
toute façon la suppression du rappel à
la loi et est attendu parce qu'on voyait
bien l'inefficacité de ce système donc
il fallait bien le remplacer par quelque
chose qui est a priori se doit d'être
plus efficace nous avions à un ensemble
de standards que nous avions proposé au
gouvernement notamment le fait que ce
soit probatoire à savoir que si la
personne réitéré les faits elle serait
condamnée pour les premiers faits
qu'elle n'avait commis que sept
avertissements pénale probatoire soit
limité à certaines attractions et en
tout cas pas pour les infractions de
violence et a fortiori sur les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique et
nous souhaitions aussi qu'elles soient
limitées dans le temps et qu'elle ne
puisse pas être prononcée plusieurs fois
d'affilée à l'égard du même des lynx un
grand oui à la solution proposée par le
garde des sceaux ce que oui pour le
moment nous pensons effectivement à
condition que la durée du l'approbation
soit étendue de 1 1 à 3 ans comme nous
le proposerons ce soir en séance nous
pensons que c'est un système qui peut
être efficace équipe est un premier
niveau de réponse pénale ces circulaires
même nom mais je crois que c'est en
matière de justice comme dans la vie ont
d'abord on sait toujours ce que l'on
perde on ne sait jamais ce que l'on a
après et donc il ya un problème de
méthode mais un vrai comme sur ce texte
et comme avec ce gouvernement en matière
de justice comme sur d'autres domaines
sert qu'on essaye de remplacer certes
des choses qui pouvoir des lacunes des
défaillances et de l'inefficacité y
compris un cinquième de la réponse
pénale par quelque chose qui
soudainement sort sans concertation sans
réflexion réelle donc si la réponse est
une mesure d'affichage elle ne sera pas
la solution et on a besoin effectivement
dans les shales pénale d'une première
mesure qui soit parce que pour une
grande partie des personnes concernées
oui aujourd'hui ce qu'on a eu à appeler
le rappel à la loi mais ce qui est
finalement le rappelle que chacune et
chacun nous faisons société et que donc
nous avons des règles à respecter et
bien parce qu'il respecte ses règles
nous avons les libertés qui qui en
découle le vrai problème de la confiance
là là mais selon pas bien ça seul le
titre d'ailleurs de suivi master saxons
la confiance pourquoi la confiance alors
maintenant j'aimerais vous faire réagir
à ce sondage st selon un sondage csa
commandé par le sénat 53% des français
n'ont pas confiance en la justice qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire à toutes les
sauces et des cultures d'abord c'est un
peu ça j'aurais presque envie de dire
c'est un drame démocratique parce que
quand vous avez plus de la moitié des
français qui n'ont pas confiance en la
justice ça nous réinterroger
effectivement sur les institutions et
sur celles qui sont censés permettre
d'assurer y compris l'égalité l'égalité
dans l'accès au droit à l'égalité à
s'ajuster fiction on creuse davantage
sur ce sondage on se rend compte qu'en
plus il ya de vraies fractures
territoriales dans ce rapport à la
justice mais le vrai souci qu'ont nos
concitoyens avec la justice c'est la
justice il c'est celle du quotidien
c'est celle à laquelle vous moi les gens
qui nous écoutent vous sont confrontés
et donc on ne répond pas cet engin d'une
justice de proximité d'une justice à
laquelle on donne les moyens y compris
pour lui permettre d'agir plus
efficacement plus rapidement sans être
dans des délais qui ne sont pas
justifiées par les besoins parce que
parfois les a besoin de temps pour un
certain handicap notamment domaine pénal
et donc c'est de cela dont il faut que
nous discutions et finalement monde issu
de la grande et le grand défaut de ce
talent je sais qu'on puisse parler de ça
mais en discutant justice discute
beaucoup de justice or la judée mâle
marron mais la justice civile us du
quotidien celle qui fait que l'on pourra
demain redonner cette confiance mais
aussi de la présence de la sécurité
moncef huile dans un département et dans
un dans une partie du département où il
a fallu qu'on se bat pendant plus de 15
ans tout élu confondues pour obtenir les
moyens nécessaires en matière de zones
de police donc c'est un ensemble c'est
cet ensemble la cour donnera demain
confiance dans l'institution chèrement
la capacité finalement à ce que ses
problèmes ses soucis du quotidien qui
deviennent parfois inferno à vivre soit
réellement résolu s'entraîner et sans
attendre et sans les ce et reporter à
demain à la question et franchement ce
texte me répond pas et l'attitude du
garde des sceaux est compris dans le
débat démocratique qui doit être celui
c1 depuis hier n'est pas à la hauteur tu
as canet vous êtes d'accord c'est le
débat droite gauche là dessus sur le
constat non sur le constat nous le
partageons en toute façon il résulte et
c'est ce qui est ressorti de l'agora de
la justice lundi j'ai tenu lundi au
sénat et où nous avons débattu de cette
réflexion sur comment redonner confiance
dans la justice si vous avez des
propositions nous avons fait cette
proposition et qui ont été échangés avec
les professionnels de la justice
effectivement le constat c'est que les
français ne sont pas confiants la
justice parce qu'elle est avant tout
trop lente trop laxiste et trop opaque
donc c'est maintenant que ce constat est
partagé comment on trouve les solutions
effectivement on vous l'avait dit je
pense que la méthode employée n'est pas
la bonne cette rafale de textes plus
d'un texte par an et cette perpétuelle
réforme de la justice n'est pas le moyen
aujourd'hui d'apaiser les professionnels
geste is parce que paradoxe quand même
dans cette étude c'est que les français
font plutôt confiance au personnel aux
acteurs de la justice avocats magistrats
etc c'est l'institution dans sa
globalité qui n'assure pas cette
confiance est donc aujourd'hui on voit
bien que les professionnels des mandats
justice souffre et il souffre d'un
manque de moyens même si aujourd'hui on
voit que les crédits du but du million
cent pour l'année prochaine mais quand
vous allez à la rencontre des
professionnels il n'y a pas encore
vraiment de ressenti parce que il y à
des réformes à digérer régulièrement on
a voté la réforme de la justice pénale
des mineurs aux mois de février ou en
train
demain les trams sont tout juste arrivé
dans les juridictions c'est une première
chose et ensuite nous au niveau du
travail parlementaire à peine
internationale est elle voter le texte
en première lecture qu'on nous propose
des états généraux de la justice à peine
la bon nombre qui commenceront le 18
octobre commence à avoir un peu de
d'éléments sur le sujet à peine nous en
commission du sénat on en a débattu sur
ce texte que le présent à un public
annonce dans le bourg de la sécurité une
réforme totale de la procédure pénale
donc si vous voulez parmi toutes les
propositions que vous faites si vous
deviez en retenir une
moi je pense que dans les propositions
il y en a beaucoup mais il est clair que
et jeu là je rejoins cécile que kerman
l'enjeu c'est la justice du quotidien
c'est la justice de proximité c'est la
justice civile 2,25 millions d'affaires
relève de la justice civile alors que
seuls huit cent dix mille affaire relève
du pénal donc on voit bien que les
français quand ils ont affaire injustice
c'est avant tout pour la justice civile
donc là il ya des réformes de fond pour
recentrer le rôle du magistrat sur la
fonction de juger pour accompagner le
magistrat par un pool de greffiers un
pôle de autour du juge qui lui redonnera
sa force et la possibilité de traiter
dans des délais rapides ce que c'est ça
que veulent aussi les français c'est des
délais rapides un suivi de leurs
affaires et c'est une des réformes
principal qui me paraît essentiel
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur cette
scène qui s'est déroulée
dans les missives vous l'avez sans doute
vous l'avez sans doute vu cet accrochage
très vif entre philippe bas et eric
dupond moretti
le différend portait sur le bilan du
gouvernement en matière de justice
écouter les deux hommes se connaissent
bien nous ne pouvons pas vous laisser
dire que les forfaits pour la justice
permet une remise à niveau telles
qu'elles seraient nécessaires dans un
discours un peu fumeux purement
politicien à eau souffrait souffrait je
vous réponde je vous réponds avec des
chiffres vous comprenez je vous réponds
avec des chiffres parce qu à vous
entendre nous n'avons rien fait le
pardon gg la parole un instant
souffrez que je vous réponde je vais
vous répondre parce que c'est
insupportable
la critique pour la critique
cécile cukierman sur le bilan du
gouvernement en matière de justice si
vous devez donner une note de 1 10 avec
moi je t'aime pas de note d'abord parce
que je suis une femme politique et donc
je suis pas dans ce jeu là et je n'ai
même pas commenter ce qui s'est passé
pour moi depuis hier depuis hier je suis
sur ce texte le choix du garde des
sceaux c'est de ne pas nous répondre et
je vais même vous donner un exemple que
vous pourrez retrouver dans les archives
de la séance à un moment donné sur un
des amendements que j'ai défendu la
commission par l'intermédiaire de ses
rapporteurs demandent l'avis du
gouvernement nous ne l'avons pas eue
voilà donc on a la garde des sceaux qui
a décidé de transformer l'hémicycle du
sénat dans un show politique
je crois qu'il y à un non sens et c'est
ce que j'ai rappelé hier soir
tardivement ici nous sommes au sénat
nous avons des débats politiques
contradictoires parce que c'est la
démocratie
et cette démocratie à l'ensemble est
confiée pour la justice
donc oui il ya un an monnaies nous ne
sommes pas là pour faire des tours de
passe passe comme dans un prétoire et
voyez je vous le
disait ma collègue agnès 15 hectares est
une réalité les françaises et français
ont confiance dans leurs avocats dans
leurs juges mais cet ensemble que l'on
appelle l'institution ses terres ce tout
qu à du lait qui ne répondent pas à
leurs préoccupations et le gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'il nous propose le présent
dans la pluie des états généraux n'en
propose pas que ça
on attend de voir la partition
territoriale depuis voilà ce que moment
donné il ya des discours de réalité
c'est ça fait dix ans que je suis sa
maîtrise donc des annonces j'ai fait
plusieurs quinquennat des annonces
d'augmentation du budget a maintenant
j'attends de voir la réalité
territoriale de ces augmentations mais
on est enfin quinquennat et on fait des
états généraux mais attendez je crois
qu'il ya on devrait reprendre la
formulation même de l'est des états
généraux donc non on ne répond pas
aujourd'hui et il n'y a pas de volonté
si ce n'est à utiliser ce malaise qui se
traduire dans les chiffres de ce sondage
à des fins qui ne sont pas celles de
s'attaquer réellement et nous savons en
débat sur comment s'y attaquer mais d'un
constant en tout cas partagé qui est que
nous avons besoin d'une justice de
proximité plus efficace plus forte et
plus rapide tout en respectant le temps
des différentes procédures agnès canayer
sur ces états généraux de la justice un
don par les cécile kuperman ces états
généraux doivent s'ouvrir le 18 octobre
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous bah
écoutez pas grand chose à vrai dire ces
états généraux de la justice ils ont été
annoncés au début de l'été je vous
rappelle quand même qu'on va rentrer
dans une période des chances électorales
majeures pour notre pays où chacun va
être amené à défendre ses idées défendre
son programme c'est la force de la
démocratie
mener des états généraux à quelques mois
de l'ouverture d'une campagne
présidentielle ça me paraît être un peu
tardif et je vois mal comment on va
pouvoir débattre sereinement d'un sujet
qui nécessite que l'on réfléchisse
collectivement je rappelle quand même
que la confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire c'est la base de notre pacte
républicain et ça impose et c'est vrai
que ce que l'on a vu dans l'hémicycle
hier soir et où philippe bas affirmé à
cette réalité a suscité aussitôt une
réaction vive de kourou très politique
du garde des sceaux or d'une part c'est
pas l'adn du scénar sénat on est là pour
débattre d'idées idée débattent de
manière constructive on n'est pas
toujours d'accord et c'est ce qui fait
la force du débat néanmoins il un
respect il ya une construction commune
c'est que le garde des sceaux a manqué
de respect aux sénateurs et de respect
mais il est monté très rapidement
en tension comme on le dit je pense
qu'il n'y avait pas matière à réagir
aussi fortement aussi vigoureusement
alors on pense que ça fait partie
peut-être de son mode de fonctionnement
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'au sénat c'est
toujours d'étonnant puisque même si on
se dit les choses même si on est capable
de s'opposer néanmoins nos discussions
sont toujours franche et cordiale et
souvent très respectueuse de la position
des uns et des autres et je pense que
les états généraux en tout cas pour y
revenir arrive trop tardivement et ne
permettront pas les réformes nécessaires
qui sont des réformes de fond tout comme
l'annoncent de la réforme de la
procédure pénale elle est attendue elle
est nécessaire que trois mois sous 3
mois à 6 mois d'une échéance
présidentielle
selon vous c'est pas possible c'est la
liste comment vous n'a jamais vu le
sénat votée par le parlement votait dans
des délais aussi rapprochés
je pense que des parlementaires
n'auront pas le temps dès lors compte en
plus dans une période budgétaire
d'adopter cette réforme si vous savez
quand on veut rétablir la confiance le
pire c'est de ne pas le faire jusqu'au
bout et donc quand on a un texte qui
s'intitule ainsi et qui ne répond pas à
la hauteur des enjeux quand comme nous
le dira chacune avec nos mots on lance
des états généraux dans un temps que le
calendrier politique ne m'empêchera pas
de réformer en profondeur
bien je ne suis pas sûr que l'on règle
saleté sur la confiance et je crains
même que l'on n'en rajoute sur une
utilisation politique de la justice
alors celle-ci doit rester indépendante
c'est d'un des fondements de notre
république et notre démocratie à la
française
14h46 les questions d'actualité vont
débuter dans moins d'un quart d'heure
maintenant on va rejoindre tout de suite
jean m'a scié gens vous allez suivre ces
questions d'actualité avec votre
communauté et oui absolument civ écoute
les internautes
rare de voir la séance de questions au
gouvernement il ya notamment des sujets
d'actualité qui les intéressent
particulièrement je pense à l'appel du
mali à la force wagner ces fameux
mercenaires sous influence russe qui
interviendrait au mali à la place
laissée vacante par la france ça pose
des questions on aimerait bien entendre
jean yves le drian qui pourrait répondre
sur sur ce sujet là on a aussi la
question du budget 2022 dernier budget
du quinquennat est ce qu emmanuel macron
et le gouvernement ne sont pas en train
de faire un peu la voilà la foire à la
dépense en pleine campagne
présidentielle emmanuel macron n'est pas
encore candidat m'enfin ce budget
ressemble quand même beaucoup un budget
de campagne et puis des questions plus
spécifiques sur le chèque énergie le
soutien au français pour faire face à la
hausse notamment du prix du gaz pour les
chaudières c'est très bien mais les
internautes aimeraient bien savoir quel
quel dispositif ils existent pour aider
à trouver des modes alternatifs de
chauffage plus économes en énergie voilà
un peu les sujets qui intéressent le
plus aujourd'hui merci beaucoup de gens
vous retrouve tout à l'heure après la
séance j'aimerais vous faire réagir à
présent sur cette annonce de gabriélat
talent tout à l'heure gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement a annoncé
que le gouvernement comptait prolonger
le passé ni terre jusqu'à l'été prochain
pour l'instant si on en croit le texte
qui a été adopté par le parlement le pas
il peut le gouvernant peut imposer le
passé une terre jusqu'au 15 novembre
est-ce que selon vous c'est judicieux de
le prolonger jusqu'à l'été agnès canayer
bah écoutez moi j'étais favorable au
passage terre puisque je pense que c'est
un moyen de retrouver une dose de
liberté et on le voit aujourd'hui grâce
à ce passe sanitaire vacciner ou pas
parce que ça peut être aussi à l'issue
de tests on peut retrouver une vie
sociale qui est très attendu aujourd'hui
on voit bien que la pandémie recul mais
qu'elle n'est pas stoppée on ne sait pas
quel ce qui va se passer dans les mois à
venir je pense pour moi qu'il est plutôt
sage de prolonger le pass annie terre
mais jusqu'à l'été je dire quel argent
les l'élection présidentielle et les
élections législatives
oui écouter
les français aussi besoin d'avoir un peu
de visibilité et donc la difficulté
enfin le problème c'est qu'on pourra
toujours stopper je pense si c'est
nécessaire aujourd'hui on voit que c'est
pour moi encore un peu prématuré de de
repousser maintenant je pense que
effectivement jusqu'à l'été c'est un peu
long et que sur ce sujet il est
nécessaire comme l'a toujours défendu le
sénat qui est des débats parlementaires
régulier et peut-être que il faudra
mettre une dalle de revoyure plus
récente plus proche est en tout cas
c'est ce que j'espère alors il ya
quelqu'un qui aura sûrement quelque
chose à dire sur la question c'est
philippe bas l'ancien président de la
commission des lois qui est avec vous
quand un d'autant que philippe bas était
rapporteur bonjour rapportant de tous
les projets de loi sanitaire depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire monsieur bah
un mot sur cette annonce de gabriella
talent en sortie du conseil des
ministres le 13 octobre prochain un
projet de loi pourrait être présenté sur
le bureau du conseil des ministres avec
l'idée de proposer de maintenir jusqu'à
l'été la possibilité je cite de recourir
aux pinces sanitaire qu'en pensez vous
nous avons autorisé
l'utilisation du pass sanitaire
seulement jusqu'au 15 novembre
la loi est entrée en vigueur le 9 août
nous sommes un peu plus que la moitié du
chemin
il va y avoir encore quelques semaines
qui vont se passer nous devons évaluer
la situation sanitaire est la situation
des vaccinations au moment de prendre
une nouvelle décision je trouve qu'il
est beaucoup trop tôt pour le faire et
je trouve que quand on aura atteint un
taux d'immunisation de la population
suffisant par la vaccination
il faudra prendre l'habitude de lutter
contre le coc vide par d'autres moyens
que les contraintes exercées sur les 85
ou 90% de personnes vaccinées pour la
protection des 10% qui ne le serait pas
et qui devront alors prendre des mesures
pour assurer leur propre sécurité
sanitaire par le respect d'un certain
nombre de gestes et de précautions à
prendre si on n'est pas vaccinée on doit
prendre des précautions particulières ce
n'est pas tout la population qui doit
les prendre pour vous on entend vous
appelez à différencier les mesures
restrictives des libertés individuelles
en fonction de son statut de vaccination
un mot sur cette date de l'été ça semble
une perspective très lointaine est ce
que c'est ce serait envisageable pour
vous de voter un texte qui donnerait de
telles échéances non je ne veux pas
différencier les contraintes je veux
dire qu'on ne va pas appliquer des
contraintes pour toute la population
parce que 10% ne seraient pas vaccinés
ou 15% ne seraient pas vaccinés donc je
veux pouvoir faire un bilan exact car
avant de proposer une décision au sénat
et en tout état de cause jamais depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire mais
jamais non plus quand il s'est agit de
lutter contre le terrorisme avec l'état
d'urgence contre le terrorisme nous
n'avons autorisé le gouvernement à
exercer en quelque sorte les pleins
pouvoirs pour lutter contre la crise
pendant une aussi longue période donc il
y aura à coup sûr un débat très
approfondie sur l'ensemble de ces
questions allez un mot maintenant si
vous le voulez bien sur l examen du
projet de loi dit de confiance en la
justice qui a commencé hier on a vu un
échange tendu entre vous et le garde des
sceaux alors que pensez vous de ce qui
s'est passé hier eric dupond moretti et
at il perdu son sang froid selon vous
oui j'ai remarqué que le garde des
sceaux était tendue mais moi je ne
l'était pas et j'ai énoncé un certain
nombre de chiffres qui n'ont pas été
contesté la suprématie de consommation
des crédits de la justice est un vrai
problème pour l'administration de la
justice il ne sert à rien d'augmenter
les crédits si les crédits ne sont pas
consommés hors en 2018 2019 2020
368 millions de crédits non consommés et
si on compte les seuls crédits
d'investissement
670 millions de crédits non consommés
canton construction de places de prison
si on atteint en mai prochain à cinq ans
après le début du quinquennat 3500
places ouvertes au lieu des quinze mille
ce sera déjà très bien compte tenu de
l'état d'avancement des chantiers donc
c'est un engagement présidentiel
centrale qui est non tenues et je crois
qu'il faut le dire avec honnêteté un
dernier mot philipp a très rapide mais
est ce que il se prête à un exercice
digne d'un prétoire dans le parlement
est ya un problème de coût préhension de
l'exercice ministériel avec eric
dupond-moretti selon mais franchement
chacun a sa personnalité je respecte la
personnalité du ministre de la justice
je n'ai pas de reproches personnel à lui
faire je souhaite simplement que notre
débat se fasse serainement et que si il
doit contester les chiffres qu'il le
fasse je constate qu'il ne l'a pas fait
merci merci fils et madame a répondu à
toutes ses questions en direct ici aux
mycoses phoenix merci beaucoup merci
quand on est justement on va eric dupond
moretti qui arrive progressivement en
salle des conférences elle est peut-être
le croiser quentin et philippe bas va
peut-être aussi de voir le croiser
cécile cukierman est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que dit philippe bas
avant de prolonger ce pass sanitaire
après le 15 novembre il faut faire un
bilan général vous savez je crois qu'en
matière de sécurité sanitaire on revient
à au débat qu'on avait sur la justice on
a besoin d'une confiance et je crois que
me laver avec les débats qui ont animé
compris une partie de la population cet
été avec de très nombreux excès on a dit
on en place le pass sanitaires jusqu'au
15 novembre parce que le parlement
d'ailleurs il comprit le sénat a poussé
parce qu'on n'est pas endetté jusqu'au
31 décembre donc faisons attention parce
que l'on ne peut pas d'un côté dire les
chiffres semblent s'améliorer manche
l'épidémiologiste un jeu
donc je prends les chiffres comme lidl
est un comble et commentent et je ne
permettrai pas plus et dans dans le même
temps on veut dire et en même temps dire
on va repousser jusqu'à l'été la mise en
place du pass sanitaires on a si on veut
que ça marche et ça a plutôt bien marché
d'ailleurs voilà cet été si on veut que
ça marche on a besoin d'une confiance de
la société mais m2 chacune et chacun
pour que ces efforts là fonctionne au
quotidien pour moi je suis très surprise
dans les annonces qui sont hâtés une
chose est sûre c'est que ce n'est pas
possible de donner un blanc-seing
jusqu'au mois de juillet est donc
élections présidentielles j'ai fait pas
jouer élections législatives le
parlement non ne partent pas en vacances
et donc il y aura besoin régulièrement
vincent rouillard et travaux du
parlement sont censé s'arrêter mais il
savait qu'on voit ce que c'est parce que
parce qu'il vient un compromis en effet
en une heure nous arrêtons mais s'il
faut il peut y avoir des sessions
extraordinaires et nous en avons connu
une d'ailleurs pour répondre à
l'accélération traumatique chez chez nos
amis autres amarin donc de toutes les
façons on ne peut pas aujourd'hui donner
un blanc-seing jusqu'au mois de juillet
donc je crois que faisons attention à
marc daou nous dit oui puis si les deux
hypothèses
nous en sommes nous verrons phantom où
nous en sommes parce qu'on nous annoncer
les chiffres catastrophiques qui nos
soins donc je crois qu'on a appris que
avec cette épidémie
parler à quinze jours est certainement
très ambitieux donc attendons voyant les
chiffres prenons les mesures moi je je
je dis tranquillement et d'un groupe a
voté contre au mois de juin la mise en
place du pass sanitaire s'est plutôt
bien passé quoi dans différentes
manifestations auxquelles les uns les
autres voilà la vaccination est sur de
bons rails pour le reste pour les
français c'est le premier prêche de la
pandémie la vie des françaises et
français mois à venir du gouvernement
non mais
on est dans un pays où on a eu des
milliers de morts donc la question n'est
pas de sauver le gouvernement la
question est de sauver les français face
à cette situation donc je crois qu'il
faut qu'on prenne les choses une par une
et que l'on avance et donc si de
nouvelles mesures doivent être prises il
faudra justifier que sanitairement elles
sont indispensables et nécessaires après
tous les efforts qui ont été consentis
par chacune et chacun nous dans notre
vie du quotidien depuis maintenant plus
d'un mois agnès canayer en 30 secondes
vous avez le mot de la fin sur sept ce
manque de confiance du coup c'est mon
enfance envers le gouvernement dont par
le cécile cukierman vous êtes d'accord
sur le sujet sanitaires sur le sujet
sanitaires alors je pense que les
français sont assez partagés c'est à
dire qu'à la fois ils ont conscience que
c'est une crise forte et qu' on n'avait
pas les solutions avec le gouvernement
essaye d'y répondre néanmoins on voit
que dans cette manière de naviguer à vue
on a besoin aussi de perspectives et des
français ont besoin d'être rassurés et
de trouver le juste équilibre et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai par ces mesures
qui s'annoncent les unes après les
autres sans perspectives aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de quoi rassurer redonner
confiance aux français leur autre sujet
d'actualité un hommage sera rendu par le
sénat à maxime blasco dans à peu près
quatre minutes ce soldat français a été
tué et un vendredi dernier au mali pour
en parler quand un vous êtes avec
christian cambon le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères tout
à fait steve et christian cambon qui
d'ailleurs va représenter le président
du sénat à l'hommage qui va être rendu à
16h30 à maxime blasco aux invalides
bonjour qu'ils s'entendront bonjour un
mot sur le message qui va être lu en
ouverture de la séance qu'elle est et
bien le message adressé aujourd'hui à
maxime glace quoi c'est assez proche
c'est un message d'émotion c'est un
message douloureux car une fois de plus
le 52e soldats que nous perdons
dans les opérations opex au mali
une émotion toute particulière car le
sergent-chef blasco qui a été promu
sergent entre temps était quelqu'un que
nous connaissions bien pour ses hauts
faits d'armes notamment la manière tout
à fait extraordinaire avec laquelle il a
agi en sauvant deux de ses compagnons
leur hélicoptère en et en 2019 s'est
écrasé et alors que lui-même avait les
vertèbres brisées il a réussi à sauver
ces deux malheureux qui était évidemment
qu'ils risquaient la mort et c'était un
soldat d'un courage et d'une simplicité
en plus qui ont fait la fierté de nos
forces armées et c'est pour ça que je
serai bien volontiers tout à l'heure aux
invalides pour lui rendre hommage on
sent que vous était ému il ya une
émotion particulière aussi au sein de
l'armée vous pensez en ce moment au sein
des armées au sein du duo ça ici du
sénat ce matin la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense que
j'ai l'honneur de présider lui a aussi
rendu hommage et tout le monde comprend
que la présence des forces françaises au
sahel ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas une simple figure c'est une
réalité concrète et au moment où les
déclarations du premier ministre malien
aux nations unies tomber véritablement
de la manière la plus désagréable je
pense que cet hommage a toute son
importance
on va expliquer à nos téléspectateurs le
premier ministre malien parle d'un
abandon en plein vol le site de la
france vers le mali la ministre florence
parly a déjà dénoncé ces propos qu'en
pensez-vous à elle a bien fait de taper
du poing sur la table ce sont des propos
parfaitement scandaleux en plus le
lendemain même où nous avons enregistré
ce décès je trouve que ces déplacés
c'est totalement contraire à la réalité
nous redéployons barkan en accord du
reste avec les autorités locales qui
avaient été prévenus je pense que c'est
tout à fait malheureux de tenir ce
langage alors même que le gouvernement
malien s'apprête à vouloir signer avec
les milices wagner qui sont des russes
déguisé un dernier mot très rapide qui
sont cambon votre commission doit
auditionner ce soir jean-yves le drian
quel sera votre message sur la fin des
sous marins nous voulons savoir ce qui
s'est véritablement passé et nous allons
continuer nos investigations pour
comprendre comment ce triste dossier a
pu échouer de cette manière merci je
vous libère touché pour puissiez vous
rendre dans l'hémicycle merci à
christian cambon on va retrouver aux
rêves états c'est votre première en
tribune de presse dites nous tout audrey
sur ce qui va se jouer aujourd'hui dans
cette séance et bien quand on vous en
avait parlé avec votre invité christian
cambon la séance va commencer par un
hommage extrêmement solennelle aux
servants chef
maxime blasco qui est décédé la semaine
dernière en opérations au mali le
pupitre vient d'être installé pour que
gérard larcher puisse prononcer un
discours pour saluer le courage et
l'engagement du militaire l'opération
barkan dans laquelle il était engagé
devrait aussi faire l'objet de plusieurs
questions posées notamment à florence
parly que j'ai vu s'installer juste
derrière moi il va falloir maintenant
savoir quelle forme va prendre
l'opération barkan puisque emmanuel
macron a annoncé la fin de cette
apparition comme de la connaissons mais
la cloche vient de sonner vous l'avez
entendu je vous laisse écouter les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
on part aussi d'observation
il y en a t'il en séance
je n'en vois point notre procès verbal
est donc adoptée sous les réserves
d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
c'est avec tristesse que nous avons
appris hier le décès de notre ancien
collègue paul girod qui fut sénateur de
l'aisne de 1978 à 2008 et qui préside à
nos très nombreux séance depuis las le
plateau comme vice président du sénat
tout au long de sa vie politique paul
girot fut un homme de conviction et
d'engagement
ces conditions il est défendu avec
intelligence passion et mesures au sein
de notre assemblée notamment lors des
débats sur le projet de loi portant
abolition de la peine de mort dont nous
commémorons le 40e anniversaire dont il
fut rapporteur devant le sénat et que
finalement il vota
je pense aussi à son infatigable
implication dans nos travers et au sein
des commissions des finances et des lois
pour défendre l'aménagement du
territoire et l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales
je le cite devant le sénat on ne pourra
pas faire de vincent les collectivités
territoriales comme on l'a fait hier
parce qu'en définitive c'est l'adhésion
de notre population à l'idée même de
république qui passe par son adhésion à
la gestion de ce qu'il connaît le mieux
la collectivité locale avec laquelle
elle est en contact permanent
conseiller régional vice président du
conseil régional de picardie
il présida ensuite son département de
l'aisne pendant dix ans maire de la
commune de droit zee depuis 1958 il
venait d'être réélu pour un deuxième
mandat consécutif
mr l'an dernier devenant ainsi le plus
ancien maire de france c'était pour lui
le nouveau de monde ce record qui
l'amusé témoigner de son attachement
malade et il pour lui le plus
passionnant il témoigne aussi et surtout
de son extraordinaire engagement
au service de son territoire et de ses
concitoyens il a servi la france avec
sincérité
il lui disait encore à l'aube de sa
dernière réélection ce n'est pas du
dévouement c'est un honneur
au nom du sénat tout entier je veux
assurer sa famille et ses proches de
notre sympathie
paul girot était enracinée dans ses
terres de l'aisne qui avait été le
théâtre de terribles combats lors de la
première guerre mondiale une terre qui a
tant souffert notre pays
monsieur le premier ministre et dames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est avec la même émotion
que nous avons appris la disparition du
cher jean maxime de lascaux tombé
vendredi dans le cadre d'une action de
combat de l'opération barkan
au nom du sénat tout entier je veux
saluer le courage l'abnégation de ce
soldat mort pour la france en luttant
contre le terrorisme djihadiste au sahel
en notre nom à tous cheveux assurer sa
famille
de notre profonde compassion à leur
présenter nos condoléances les plus
attristées
sa carrière vue militaire fut marquée
par de multiples actes héroïques décoré
par le président de la république de la
médaille militaire il fut avant tout un
exemple à la fois de courage et
d'humilité
fait partie de ces hommes dont il ne
faut pas attendre qu'il soit mort au
champ d'honneur pour prendre conscience
qu'ils sont grands je pense à ses frères
d'armes de la force barkan et du 7e
bataillon de chasseurs alpins qui
s'inspire de son courage et du même
amour de la france
deux hommes
deux hommes à l'histoire très
différentes qui ont servi notre pays
avec dévouement et grandeur je vous
demande d'observer une minute de silence
en leur hommage
non merci
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
nous sommes retransmis en direct sur
public sénat et notre site internet sur
lequel sera
attentif au respect les uns et des
autres et en celui du temps de parole et
je donne la parole
un autre collègue joël bigot pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues le
prix du gaz va bondir de 12 et demi pour
cent ce vendredi al'approche de la
saison hivernale une augmentation qui
selon la commission de régulation de
l'énergie perdurera jusqu'au printemps
prochain et qui représente une dépense
supplémentaire de 600 euros par foyer
sur le nez sans compter l'augmentation
parallèle du prix de l'électricité que
les associations de consommateurs
estiment à environ 10% le renflouement
du chèque énergie de 100 euros est une
bonne nouvelle sachant que nous la
demandons chaque année depuis 2000 19
néanmoins il est urgent de trouver de
nouveaux outils de régulation du prix de
l'énergie par le biais de la tva
toujours à 20% sur le gaz et
l'électricité les recettes de l'état
vont progresser la baisse même
temporaire du taux de tva est une piste
parmi d'autres pour venir en soutien aux
français qui voient leur pouvoir d'achat
mis mise à mal en italie en espagne les
gouvernements ont déjà baissé les taxes
pour amortir les effets sur les ménages
il s'agit là de dépenses contraintes
incompressibles et de première nécessité
pour l'ensemble des ménages si rien
n'est fait la précarité énergétique qui
touche déjà 7 millions de nos
concitoyens
explosera et aggravera encore la
paupérisation massive mise en évidence
dans un récent rapport de l'insee
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
annoncé des mesures supplémentaires dans
les tout prochains jours pouvez-vous
aujourd'hui rassurer les français en
présentant les options qui sont sur
votre table en vue du débat budgétaire
au parlement qu'allez vous faire
traitement et dès maintenant pour aider
les français qui ne pourront pas faire
face
on vous répondre la parole est à eux
mêmes la secrétaire d'état chargé de la
biodiversité madame ah bah vous avez la
parole d'un ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bigot vous l'avez dit oui
effectivement nous connaissons une forte
hausse du prix de l'énergie une hausse
qui est repose pour beaucoup sur celle
du prix du gaz dans un contexte de
reprise économique mondiale avec donc
une augmentation de la demande et
parallèlement une réduction des
productions russe et est norvégienne or
la france vous le savez importe 99 % du
gaz naturel qu'elle consomme ces
évolutions des marchés internationaux
ils sont donc elles ont donc des
conséquences sur les tarifs de cette
vente de gaz et elles impactent
directement 2,8 millions de ménages avec
des conséquences sur les tarifs
réglementés alors même que face à cette
situation est due à des facteurs
extérieurs on le redit les français sont
protégés de ces variations par l'arenh
et les tarifs réglementés qui atténue
fortement cette hausse cependant il faut
que nous allions plus loin il faut
effectivement que nous agissions plus
avant dans ce dans ce contexte nous
agissons en déployant et en renforçant
vous le savez le chèque énergie un
chèque qui a bénéficié à près de 6
millions de foyers avec un montant moyen
l'an passé de 150 euros qui pouvait
monter jusqu'à 2 177 euros et qui sera
renforcé dans ce contexte exceptionnel
par un chèque exceptionnelle de 100
euros qui sera versée directement dans
les boîtes aux lettres de ses 6 millions
de bénéficiaires avant la fin de l'année
ces chèques énergie il se renouvelleront
en 2022 en est envoyé directement dans
les boîtes aux lettres des français en
mars avec également la prime rénove qui
doit permettre aux français par des
aides à la rénovation énergétique à la
fois de réduire nos consommations
énergétiques mais aussi de faire baisser
leur facture et nous avons dans ce dans
ce cadre une urgence à mettre en place
effectivement des dispositifs de plus
court terme en relais de ces dispositifs
de moyens et en terme le premier
ministre a donc eu le lot rappelé hier
nous travaillons et nous souhaitons vous
proposer des dispositifs qui permettent
de faire face à cette situation
exceptionnelle je vous remercie monsieur
bigot
[Musique]
oui j'entends bien votre réponse madame
la ministre ma prime rénove est une
opération à moyen et long terme ce que
les français attendent ce sont des
mesures immédiates j'en ai proposé
quelques unes la baisse de la tva
d'autres mesures de cette nature doit
pouvoir répondre à au pouvoir d'achat
des français qui risque d'être très me
mise à mal par la situation actuelle il
faut d'urgence intervenir sur des
mesures rapides et immédiates sur ce
sujet merci merci la parole est à notre
collègue jean yves roux pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
chers collègues des collectivités
locales mairies communautés de communes
départements sont en train de négocier
des contrats d'assurance dommages et
biens et responsabilité civile pour
l'année 2022 et possède comme à
l'accoutumée à des mises en concurrence
or cette année des élus notamment du
sud-est et de l'occitanie sont
confrontés à des situations inédites des
compagnies d'assurances renommée
tonnante du risque ou non refuse de
candidater sur ces appels d'offres la
raison nous la connaissons
malheureusement le risque climatique
ces assureurs locaux ont ainsi pour mot
d'ordre de se désengager des
collectivités du bassin méditerranéen du
sud ayant subi des inondations dans les
dix dernières années ou disposant de
biens immobiliers considéré un risque
tels que des campings des abattoirs où
des pépinières d'entreprises
lorsque le très rare qu'un pagny
candidate leur politique tarifaire
explose et n'est pas négociable pour une
commune ardéchoise de 10000 habitants
l'unique candidat assureurs impose
généreusement une augmentation de 5 81%
une communauté d'agglomération de
l'hérault soit proposé un tarif passant
de 25000 euros à 167 1000 euros à un an
de la même manière les franges il
s'envole comprise entre 50000 et 150000
euros
madame la ministre dans ce contexte des
collectivités sont nus envisageant
sérieusement devenir leur propre
assureur espérant que les catastrophes
naturelles futur préserveront leur
bâtiment classé et leur capacité à agir
y compris pour prévenir des risques
climatiques madame la ministre comment
comptez vous accompagner ses nombreuses
et collectivités à faire face à cet
abandon silencieux d assurance face aux
risques climatiques je vous remercie
pour vos réponses la parole est au
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires en charge
de la ruralité ou sur le ministre merci
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs sur le sénateur cherche un
livre où ce je partage votre
préoccupation concernant les
collectivités qui indique éprouvé des
difficultés dans la négociation de leur
contrat d'assurance je voudrais tout
d'abord vous donner quelques éléments de
contexte faut comprendre cette situation
puisque dans les années récentes
un grand nombre d'assureurs se sont
intéressés aux risques subis par les
collectivités il n'était pas rare qu'une
dizaine d'entreprises répondent aux
appels d'offres formulées par les
collectivités il en découle est gic mans
une pression à la baisse sur les tarifs
des polices d'assurance depuis quelques
années les collectivités locales font
face ça utile si une sinistralité qui
croissante je pense bien sûr aux
incendies mais également aux événements
climatiques grave que vous citez
notamment dans les régions montagneuses
ou encore aux sinistres sur les
véhicules l'augmentation du coût des
risques assurables donc conduit certains
acteurs assurent routier du marché et
parallèlement les assurer vos instants
sur le marché ont augmenté leurs tarifs
par exemple en relevant les franchises à
terme cette situation pourrait présenter
un risque le premier et le plus
important est celui que certaines
collectivités renonce tout simplement à
souscrire une police d'assurance dans ce
cas le moindre événement imprévu
pourrait que leur causer des difficultés
financières absolument insurmontable je
précise que ce problème reste pour le
moment très localisées cependant même
s'il n'y a pas d' alerte au niveau
national c'est un sujet de préoccupation
que nous devons examiner de manière très
précise je propose donc avec le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
nous regardions la situation afin
d'identifier les leviers qui permettrait
aux élus de s'assurer correctement pour
esquisser une première piste une partie
de la réponse se trouve peut-être
d'ailleurs dans le fait d'accompagner
les collectivités dans leurs travaux de
protection contre les risques je pense
aux mises aux normes incendie à la
prévention des inondations sur laquelle
des financements existent sous forme de
subventions d'investissement ou de
crédit les agences de l'eau ou de
mobilisation de la taxe j'aime api un
sujet qui est que vous connaissez très
bien puisque nous travaillons déjà
ensemble sur ce point en tout état de
cause nous reviendrons vers vous sur ce
sujet qui est extrêmement important pour
les collectivités
merci la parole est au président
guillaume gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
depuis deux 2 ans le groupe ferrero
clubs spécialisés dans le silicium et le
ferro alliages engagé une
restructuration massive de ses sites
français fin mars le groupe annonce
l'arrêt de production de deux de ses
principaux sites château feuillet en
savoie et les unes des claveau en isère
ce sont 3 157 emplois qui sont menacés
357 familles qui vivent depuis plusieurs
mois dans l'incertitude du lendemain
avec la peur et la colère au ventre
production industrielle indispensable à
souveraineté de la france le silicium
équipe les panneaux solaires comme les
microprocesseurs c'est aussi un savoir
faire industriels d'excellence tout cela
est menacée par la cupidité d'un groupe
qui n'a plus grand-chose d'industriels
alors monsieur le premier ministre vous
nous avez promis ici même que vous
feriez tout pour éviter de nouvelles
délocalisations d'industrie
indispensable à notre souveraineté vous
nous avez signifier ici même que je cite
ce gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour la construction d'une filière
photovoltaïque souveraine et durable
vous avez d'ailleurs annoncé je le salue
18 milliards d'euros d'appels d'offres
de panneaux photovoltaïques mais si nous
renonçons à toute intervention publique
alors c'est 18 milliards d'euros
financeront l'industrie chinoise avec un
bilan humain et environnemental
désastreux
pourtant à ferro peine plus qu'à l'heure
les solutions sont sur la table les
salariés les organisations syndicales
ont élaboré un contre projet ambitieux
et réaliste il permettra de maintenir
l'activité sur tous les sites du groupe
et ainsi répondre aux nombreuses
commandes des prochains mois est engagée
la modernisation nécessaire des
installations alors monsieur le premier
ministre la france a et aura besoin de
silicium après deux ans d'absence sur ce
dossier vous ne pouvez pas laisser ces
au globe fermé ne serait ce qu'un seul
side nous vous donnerons demandons de
suspendre le pse d'investir dans
ferropem
et au besoin de recourir à la
nationalisation temporaire des sites
merci pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président de guillaume gontard je vous
confirme les propos que j'ai tenus dans
cette enceinte est ailleurs le
gouvernement poursuit un objectif de
relocalisation de notre pays de
reconquête de sa souveraineté
industrielle pendant trop d'années
délaissée et le dossier qui fait l'objet
de votre question est en effet
symbolique je rappelle au sénat à la
suite de ce que vous avez dit qu'il
s'agit là nous avons faire un groupe
international appelé ferro globe qui est
un grand producteur de silicium et
d'alliages de silicium et de manganèse
ce groupe a racheté en 2005 si mes
informations sont exactes la branche
électrométallurgie de pechiney ferropem
et c'est ce groupe effectivement vous
l'avez dit qui
dispose de plusieurs sites en france 6
très exactement au delà des 2 que vous
avez cités plus une usine de production
de manganèse à dunkerque
ce groupe annoncés vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président c'était en mars
dernier une vaste restructuration
au plan international
prévoyant comme vous l'avez dit la
fermeture de deux de ses sites français
en l'occurrence eu deux châteaux
feuillants savoie et d'éclats vaut dans
votre beau département de l'isère a
sorti cette annonce de la suppression de
3 157 postes de travail
je confirme au sénat et à vous-même la
pleine mobilisation de l'état pour
obtenir une inflexion forte dans les
décisions annoncées par ce groupe il
nous faut en effet comme vous l'avez dit
préserver dans le cadre de la stratégie
plus globale non seulement industriel
mais photovoltaïque que vous avez
rappelé la filière du silicium en france
qui est stratégique à plusieurs titres
dès lors qu'il s'agit de métaux clé pour
la transition écologique énergétique
pardon l'électronique et plus
généralement la résilience de nos
approvisionnements
sans compter bien entendu
ai-je besoin de dire devant le sénat des
enjeux en termes d'emplois dans les
territoires que vous avez cités alors
bien entendu je commence par l'emploi
nous surveillons de très près que les
plans de sauvegarde que vous avez cités
soient les plus ambitieux possible comme
nous le faisons par tous lorsqu'il ya
des restructurations mais vous avez
raison ça ne suffit pas ça ne suffit pas
il faut trouver
avec la direction de cette entreprise
et avec son actionnaire faire au globe
et je me réjouis que les discussions
aient pu prendre un tour nouveau depuis
septembre dernier donc quelques semaines
à peine sous l'égide d'agnès panier
relâche ministre délégué à l'industrie
pour rechercher avec eux des mesures je
le dis très clairement alternative à
l'arrêt d'exploitation de ses deux
usines c'est clairement l'objectif du
gouvernement pour trouver avec eux des
moyens permettant d'envisager le
maintien de ces deux sites de production
l'état a fait plusieurs propositions aux
dirigeants de l'europe est de ferropem
afin de leur permettre puisque c'était
la finalité du plan de restructuration
de renforcer la compétitivité des sites
en mobilisant différentes mesures de
soutien notamment c'est le fort utile et
qui seront préservés en 2022 dans le
cadre de la loi de finances qui vous
sera proposé notamment celles relevant
du plan de relance ces propositions
monsieur le président font actuellement
l'objet des changes très approfondies
avec l'entreprise avec qui je le disais
les services de l'état sont en constante
relation le processus que vous avez
évoqué de recherche de repreneurs
potentiels au titre duquel un cabinet de
consultants spécialisés ainsi que les
services de bus et france on mobilise et
se poursuit avec à ce stade quand même
je le rappelle la manifestation de huit
marques d'intérêt potentiels qui sont
analysés ne doutez pas de notre
détermination à enrayer ce qui au mois
de mars apparaissait comme inéluctable
je vois ainsi merci la parole et à notre
collègue joël guerriau pour les groupes
les indépendants
république et territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le président de la république
vient d'annoncer la défiscalisation des
pourboires par carte bancaire
cette décision va dans le même sens
qu'une question que je vous avais
adressé écrite en avril 2020 demandant à
un relèvement du plafond des paiements
sans contact à 50 euros en appliquant
cette mesure vous aviez acté que
manipuler la monnaie constituait un
risque sanitaire
de plus en plus de français d'ailleurs
utilise que la carte bancaire or parade
au lac paradoxalement certains
commerçants refusent en toute légalité
la carte bancaire en dessous d'un
certain seuil ainsi un jeune désargenté
peut acheter un fruit dans un
supermarché avec sa carte bleue mais il
sera contraint de prendre deux
consommations dans un bar acheter un
paquet de cigarettes plus un jeu à
gratter ou deux paquets de cigarettes
dans un bureau de tabac tout cela parce
qu'un seuil minimum et parfois exigé au
dessus du prix d'un seul produit comme
par hasard il est clair que le sur
l'objectif ici est de pousser à la
consommation
or il s'agit souvent de produits tels
que le tabac l'alcool les jeux dont
l'addiction est particulièrement vous
savez nocives cela fait déjà plusieurs
années que beaucoup plaident pour
modifier la loi afin de supprimer cette
pratique arbitraire de fixer un montant
minimum ma question monsieur le ministre
est simple vous et j'ai vous des mesures
permettant de répondre à cette forte
attente de notre jeunesse
on vous répond de la parole et au
ministre délégué en charge des petites
et moyennes entreprises je me suis brisé
jeune ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur joël guerriau vous
avez raison monsieur le sénateur de plus
en plus de consommateurs utilisent la
carte bancaire et maintenant le paiement
sans contact pour leurs achats
d'ailleurs se trouve tout à fait positif
que depuis quatre ans il y a maintenant
60 % de plus de commerçants qui
acceptent ces paiements de cartes
bancaires qui font l'objet de plusieurs
paiements d'abord le paiement
interbancaire 0 23% qui a été limité
pour rémunérer la banque de l'émetteur
et du récepteur ensuite il y à une
commission au prix par les
intermédiaires et puis certains
intermédiaires adaptant plus une
facturation forfaitaire par
opération ce qui amène un certain nombre
de commerçants effectivement vous avez
raison à m un montant limité pour éviter
de multiplier ces prélèvements dans le
cadre des assises du commerce que nous
allons engager au mois de novembre
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous allons
travailler d'abord pour voir avec les
opérateurs s'il est possible de diminuer
le coût
de pourcentage de prises par les
intermédiaires sur ces montants est
ensuite effectivement vous avez raison
pour permettre à l'ensemble des
consommateurs de pouvoir utiliser la
carte bancaire y compris pour des achats
modeste puisque la carte bancaire y
compris dans cette période sanitaire
compliqué a été un des moyens de pouvoir
éviter la transmission du virus par
l'ami population de la monnaie dont vous
avez raison monsieur le sénateur nous
allons travailler dans le cadre des
assises sur ce sujet et j'espère que
très rapidement on pourra répondre
positivement à votre attente
monsieur guerriau
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre de
me rassurer sur le fait que vous allez
faire en sorte de trouver des solutions
je le dis d'autant plus que nous avons
20 % de nos étudiants qui sont sous du
seuil de pauvreté nous savons aussi que
75 % d'entre eux se plaignent d'avoir
des fans m'a extrêmement difficile le
prix du logement et en est si élevé que
et surtout sur paris qu'il reste peu
souvent très peu de marge pour pouvoir
ensuite vivre en société étudiante et en
particulier comme un étudiant quand il a
payé son logement du reste pas grand
chose et un logement il est très petit
il faut bien qu'ils se retrouvent à une
terrasse d'un café avec d'autres amis
pour pouvoir échanger donc je pense que
ce sujet est vraiment important et je
vous assure qu'il a été à plusieurs
reprises soulevé par des étudiants et je
devrai bien effectivement contre une
solution une fois pour toutes il n'est
pas normal qu'un commerce l'urd un côté
prennent un montant et un autre d'un
autre montant c'est pas logique
la parole est un autre collègue alain
joyandet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président en ce moment
même où ça valide se met en place la
cérémonie en hommage au caporal-chef
masque si mme blasco comment donc ne pas
être par la pensée
autour de tous ces soldats autour de
toutes les familles qui ont perdu un
être cher autour de ses frères d'armes
et de tous ceux qui se sont engagés au
service de la france au service de la
paix ici en france ou à l'extérieur dans
ce contexte madame la ministre des
armées
l'annnonce de la réorganisation de la
force barkan est perçu comme un des
engagements de la france au sahel le
président de la république a dit lui
même que nous n'avions pas vocation à
rester au sahel le mali est en train de
négocier avec des forces russes privées
dit groupe wagner pour assurer dans
l'avenir sa sécurité alors dans ces
conditions et la blâmer ni j'ai deux
questions à vous poser
d'abord si les négociations avec les
russes et le mali aboutissent pas
d'accord qu'a donc allons nous faire que
la france va-t-elle faire en réaction à
cet accord et puis parallèlement une
autre question qu'avez vous tirer comme
enseignement comme conclusion de notre
départ précipité d'afghanistan ainsi que
celui de nos alliés des etats-unis
d'amérique merci pour vous répondre la
parole et collègues désormais l
influence par lise avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur tout d'abord permettez moi de
m'associer à l'hommage que le sénat
vient de rendre à auxerre jean maxime
blasco aux morts pour la france vous
l'avez rappelé un hommage national lui
sera rendu par la nation toute entière
cet après midi alors vous rappeler que
je me suis rendu au mali récemment et au
cours de ce voyage j'ai pu non seulement
rencontrer nos militaires engagés sur le
terrain et leur dire toute ma
reconnaissance et ma fierté mais j'ai
aussi pu rencontrer le ministre de la
défense du gouvernement de transition
malien dans un contexte où en effet
circulent des rumeurs voire des
informations selon lesquelles
le gouvernement de transition aurait
l'intention de contracter avec une
société de mercenaires
alors j'ai eu l'occasion de dire très
clairement et très directement au
ministre le malien ce que la france
pensait de wagner et ce qu'elle pensait
des mercenaires d'une manière générale
je lui ai dit aussi ce que la communauté
internationale en pensait et je le redis
ici devant la représentation nationale
si le mali engage un partenariat avec
des mercenaires
le mali s'isolera
il perdra le soutien de la communauté
internationale qui est pourtant très
engagé au mali
il abandonnera des pans entiers de sa
souveraineté il suffit de regarder ce
qui se passe en république
centrafricaine aujourd'hui est loin de
diversifier ses partenariats
le mali s'enfermera au contraire dans un
tête à tête avec une société de
mercenaires alors pour nous les choses
sont claires il n'est pas possible de
cohabiter avec des mercenaires et dans
ce contexte les propos du premier
ministre du gouvernement malien tenu à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu samedi dix
ans et sont inacceptables car accusé la
france d' abandonner le mot le mali au
lendemain de la mort d'un de nos soldats
c'est proprement indécents
monsieur joyandet
merci pour votre réponse claire madame
la mini je m'associe à votre cas vos
commentaires sur les déclarations
évidemment du premier ministre du mali
mais je voudrais vraiment insisté sur le
fait que la nation entière est
aujourd'hui en communion avec ses
soldats et nous le savons beaucoup sont
morts pour notre liberté est celle des
générations futures
souvenons nous deux faisons en sorte
madame la ministre qui ne soient pas
morts pour rien c'est un peu le
sentiment que j'ai regardons ce qui
s'est passé en afghanistan
quel gâchis et donc la bande du sahel
le parallèle n'est pas totalement
judicieux peut-être mais pas plus du
sahel la bande du sahel est vraiment un
endroit stratégique pour le monde pour
l'europe - fût-ce et pour notre liberté
est vraiment ne partons pas du sahel
nous avons vocation à y rester c'est de
notre avenir c'est notre avenir qui est
en question merci
la parole est à notre collègue
olivier cigolotti pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le groupe de l'union centriste
s'associe également à la douleur de la
famille du caporal-chef blasco nos
pensées vont également à ses proches ses
frères d'armes et tous ceux qui luttent
actuellement contre le terrorisme et ce
depuis 2013 ça a été dit un hommage
national bien légitime sera rendu cet
après midi au sergent gasco
dans le même temps à la tribune de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
le premier ministre malien du
gouvernement de transition n'hésite pas
à accuser la france d'abandonner le mali
en envisageant de réduire le format de
la force barkan il n'hésite pas non plus
à exprimer sa volonté de chercher de
nouveaux partenariats parmi les sociétés
privées para militaires russes sans
toutefois citer les milices wagner 13
pays européens impliqués pour certains
dans la coalition des forces spéciales
takouba ont jugé de telles déclarations
inacceptables
la france l'allemagne l'estonie sont
allés plus loin en avertissant qu'elle
réexaminera leur présence au mali
si un accord en ce sens était conclue
afin de sécuriser les régions en proie
aux groupes armés terrorisent de
tessalit tu kidal ou tombouctou certes
le format de l'opération extérieur
barkan devrait être vu mais la france
engagée depuis 2013 au sahel a d'ores et
déjà perdu 50 de ses soldats et doit
réorganiser sa présence à travers un
dispositif plus resserrée autour de
frappes ciblées contre les chefs
djihadistes est basé sur
l'accompagnement des armées locales
madame la ministre alors que la france a
fermement rejeté les accusations
inacceptables et indécente d'abandon du
mali
quelles suites entendez vous donner à
cette nouvelle provocation de l'état
malien je vous remercie
quand même la ministre les parlent ils
avaient la part merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous avez
évoqué les propos du premier ministre du
gouvernement de transition malien aux
nations unies et je voudrais tout
d'abord balayé une contre vérité non la
france ne se désengage pas du mali je
leur dis clairement quand on a des
milliers de soldats sur place comme
c'est notre cas aujourd'hui
lorsque on multiplie les opérations de
contre terrorisme avec des succès
tactiques notable je pense en
particulier à la neutralisation récente
du numéro un des shows sel lorsque comme
nous venons de le faire nous déployons
nos nouveaux blindés griffon abarkan au
sahel vous conviendrez avec moi que ce
n'est pas l'attitude d'un pays qui s'en
va alors oui il est tout à fait
scandaleux de faire croire au monde
entier que la france s'en va et faire
croire qu'il serait normal d'appeler au
chevet du mali un groupe de mercenaires
sous prétexte que nous rendons aux
maliens trois bases militaires dans le
nord ça c'est de la mauvaise foi
je voudrais rappeler devant vous que la
france et la communauté internationale
reste pleinement mobilisé aux côtés du
mali et je voudrais aussi rappeler
que les engagements pris par le
gouvernement de transition malien
vis-à-vis de la communauté
internationale eux ne sont pas
pleinement tenu
alors je redis mais pardonnez moi la
question bien vite combien les propos du
premier ministre malien sont choquants
particulièrement choquant dans le
contexte que vous avez rappelé monsieur
le président merci monsieur cigolotti
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole à notre collègue céline
brulin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes avaient
la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues vendredi le
tarif réglementé du gaz augmentera de
plus de 12% ce qui portera à 57% sa
hausse depuis janvier dans quatre mois
celui de l'électricité risquent de
bondir aussi de 10% percutant le pouvoir
d'achat des français déjà en berne
accroissant les charges pour nos
entreprises en particulier dans
l'industrie pesant sur les budgets de
fonctionnement de nos collectivités
alors vous avez décidé un chèque énergie
exceptionnelle à destination des foyers
les plus modestes mais les français en
quelque sorte l'auto finances une fois
en acquittant leur facture une deuxième
en payant leurs impôts et puis face à la
colère légitime
vous avez annoncé de nouvelles mesures
vous venez de le redire à l'instant sans
répondre précisément à ce que vous
entendez par là et a quel sens vous
voulez leur donner j'insiste donc
entendez vous reconnaître l'énergie
comme un bien de première nécessité en
baissant la tva sur le gaz et sur
l'électricité allez-vous supprimer la
taxe intérieure de consommation sur le
gaz naturel pour les ménages les plus
précaires et qu'on sentez-vous à mettre
à contribution par exemple angie puisque
le groupe a annoncé avoir engrangé un
bénéfice de 2,3 milliards sur les six
premiers mois de l'année et envisage
encore d'accroître son résultat je vous
remercie vous répondre la parole et à
secrétaire d'état chargée aux diversités
benhamama min
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame madame la
sénatrice brûlant effectivement cette
hausse des prix du gaz elle l impact l
impact beaucoup de ménages français avec
déjà pourtant six millions de foyers
modestes qui
son protégé de ces variations via le
chèque énergie qui est complétée dans ce
contexte exceptionnel vous l'avez dit
par une aide supplémentaire de 200 euros
qui sera versée dès le mois de décembre
et comme le premier ministre l'a
souhaité nous travaillons de travail ont
également des mesures de soutien
complémentaire qui pourrait être
présenté dans les tout prochains jours
qui doit vraiment accompagner de manière
urgente est exceptionnel cette situation
à court terme au delà donc de ses
mesures exceptionnelles nous devons
sortir de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles vous le savez c'est tout le
sens de notre politique énergétique
c'est pourquoi nous déployons aussi des
solutions pour réduire notre
consommation énergétique
c'est tout l'objet de ma prime rénove
cet été octroyées par l'état qui permet
aux français de rénover énergétiquement
leur leur logement nos concitoyens sont
massivement emparez vous le savez nous
visions 400 mille dossiers en 2021 nous
avons d'ores et déjà dépassé les 500
mille demandes et nous visons à horizon
de la fin de l'année huit cent mille
dossiers cette année sur ma prime rénove
800 mille dossiers madame ce sont autant
de ménages qui paieront moins cher leurs
factures d'énergie et de chauffage tout
en participant à la réduction de nos
consommations énergétiques et à cela
s'ajoute évidemment le mesures
structurantes 2 du projet de loi climat
résilience que vous avez bien voulu
voter mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
qui prévoit le gel de l'augmentation des
loyers des passoires thermiques a compté
2023 ou encore l'interdiction
progressive de la location de ces
passoire horizon 2025 nous avons donc
tous ces leviers de court de moyens de
long terme ces mesures qui sont au
moment même où je vous parle en train de
se dessiner nos services y travaillent
évidemment tout est sur la table vous
avez mentionné des leviers fiscaux nous
réfléchissons évidemment avec avec les
fournisseurs nous avons déjà entre les
mains des outils qui permettent
d'accompagner ponctuellement les les
foyers français nous y sommes donc
pleinement mobilisés merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais encore et insisté madame la
ministre pour vous conseiller si je peux
le dire en ces termes de baisser la tva
sur l'électricité et le gaz comme le me
demande des associations de
consommateurs comme le demande des
organisations syndicales comme nous le
demandons depuis des années maintenant y
compris nous mêmes et puis je crois que
dans ce débat il faut reconnaître
l'incapacité du marché à prendre en
compte à la fois le porte monnaie des
français mais aussi les enjeux
climatiques et à linverse des propos du
médiateur de l'énergie qui invite si je
peux le dire en ces termes les français
à changer de fournisseur comme de
chemise ce qui ne peut que renforcer la
concurrence délétère il faut penser à ce
que la puissance publique reprennent la
main sur le secteur énergétique par
exemple en nationalisant
la parole et à notre collègue alain
richer pour le groupe du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendante n'avait la parole monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur la france
vient de décider le gouvernement vient
de décider que nous allions resserré de
façon très substantielle le nombre de
visas délivrés aux ressortissants
d'algérie du maroc et de tunisie avec
d'ailleurs des proportions de réduction
différentes entre ces trois pays
je comprends la pression du gouvernement
nous autres c'est le résultat c'est une
décision prise au terme d'une
négociation prolongé avec les trois
états en question qui n'ont pas modifié
leur position et donc j'aimerais que
vous expliquer à notre assemblée elles
sont les positions que défendent ces
trois pays pour justifier de ne pas
exercer cette coopération légal minimal
entre états partenaires
seconde manche j'observe que le
gouvernement de prendre cette position
qu'elle garde ses trois pays qui ne sont
pas les seuls pays d'origine
d'immigration irrégulière en france
est ce qu'on peut en déduire que
d'autres pays partenaires eux acceptent
d'être normalement coopératifs en
matière de délivrance de certificats de
retour pour les immigrants irréguliers
et enfin troisième question est ce que
vous estimez avec nos partenaires des
affaires étrangères que les services des
consulats français dans ces trois pays
qui seront soumis à une pression
beaucoup plus forte du fait du nombre de
refus sont préparés à assumer cette
charge
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur gérald
darmanin vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le ministre
richard c'est une question vraiment très
importante dans le président de la
république a eu à décider dans un
conseil restreint la plusieurs mois de
la politique là plusieurs mois comme ses
prisons n'a réplique a donné instruction
aux produits est remise intérieure au
ministre des affaires étrangères de
réduire de façon significative le nombre
de visas accordés
aux ressentis 100 d'algérie du maroc
pour 50% un visa sur deux et 30% pour la
tunisie cela s'est fait en effet la
suite de négociations qui étaient très
particulière parce que c'est pas perdu
que vides avant la période du creux vide
les chiffres de reconduites à la
frontière et de laisser passer
consulaire n'était pas à 100% il est
vrai mais il était à plus de 50% c'est à
dire plus haut que n'importe quelle
année depuis quinze dernières années
mais depuis la période du creux vide
jouant la fois de la fermeture de
l'espace aérien et des conditions
sanitaires que nous trouvons trop
importante c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et montrant ainsi une certaine
façon de ne pas délivré de laissez
passer consulaires nous avons pris les
décisions que vous avez évoqué ses
décisions à ce bien sûr progressive
elles sont réversibles le jour où la
tunisie le maroc et l'algérie revient à
des relations normales de laisser passer
consulaire bien évidemment et au cas par
cas puisque c'est la consigne est donnée
par monsieur premier ministre à nos
ambassadeurs et aux deux ministères
évidemment nous reviendrons à une
relation si j'ose dire normal avec ces
trois pays du maghreb pour lequel nous
avons amitié et ne se tond construire
évidemment l'avenir ensemble pour les
autres pays vous avez raison de dire que
ce ne sont pas les trois seuls pays
auxquels des relations n'avons pas mis
en place ce type de dispositif parce que
les laissez passer consulaires sont
délivrés il de son dans des conditions
plus ou moins facile évidemment selon
les pays mais ils le sont et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que parmi l'opération des
1000 personnes délinquante étrangères
comme la demande établir le président de
la république nous avons déjà pu en un
mois expulsé trois cent soixante et une
personnes sortant de prison alors même
que les conditions sanitaires empêche
sans doute d'être encore plus efficace
monsieur richard
notre collègue thierry bnia qui prend la
parole pour la première fois comme
sénateur dans notre magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour le gym donc monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
on a rétabli la double peine en
seine-saint-denis
je m'explique à travers la décision de
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur de
déplacer les toxicomanes du jardin
d'eole vers la seine-saint-denis
et d'autre part les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis subissent la politique
menée par la mairie de paris qui tend de
plus en plus souvent à transférer ses
problèmes vers les départements
limitrophes et donc également la seine
saint denis alors j'aborde cette
question par le biais de la toxicomanie
j'aurais pu la bordée par le biais de
différents sujets les trafics en tous
genres la prostitution le l'immigration
illégale la délinquance le fond reste le
même pari déverse vers la banlieue et
vers la seine-saint-denis aujourd'hui
pantin aubervilliers un certain nombre
de ces de ces problèmes et je le dis
avec fermeté la seine saint denis ne
peut pas devenir le dépotoir
alors nous sommes un certain nombre
d'élus de ce département à nous battre
avec conviction dans la difficulté
c'est vrai qu'un plan a été de
développement de la seine saint denis a
été
élaborer et posée par monsieur le
premier ministre mais à quoi bon si
parallèlement on nous ajoute au problème
que nous avons déjà d'autres problèmes
j'ai le souvenir de serge gainsbourg qui
chantait dans les années 80 je dis aux
dealers
casson la gueule aux dealers on en est
bien loin aujourd'hui puisque on nous
aurions pu sur le sujet qui nous
préoccupe
mettre en place un centre de désintox de
désintoxication d'ailleurs valérie
pécresse l'a proposé c'est du
pragmatisme lâche la solution qui a été
choisie c'est une fois de plus de
déplacer le problème et de le déplacer
au delà du boulevard périphérique alors
je crois que la seine-saint-denis
souffre finalement probablement d'être
un petit peu éloigné d'une part des
préoccupations du gouvernement et
d'autre part d'être un petit peu trop
proche
des frontières de la ville de paris
alors monsieur le ministre que comptez
vous faire comment allez vous le faire
pour régler cette question les habitants
de la seine-saint-denis ne pense qu'à
une chose ne demande qu'une chose
pouvoir vivre normalement
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur norman
eh
bien monsieur le président messieurs les
sénateurs mais le sénateur d'abord de
parlons de femmes d'hommes et d'enfants
et non pas de déchets d'ordures ou
d'immondices
je voudrais les rappeler toxicomane ty
lawson du crack à paris depuis plus de
20 ans chacun le sait
c'est vrai que longtemps on a fermé les
yeux sur cette question
concentration dans le jardin d'eole
devant la situation inacceptable inverse
de la mairie de paris a fermé ce jardin
et sont ensuite allés rubik et noah
tourne à briquet ou en moins de quinze
jours il ya plus d'une dizaine
d'agressions à caractère sexuel et à
caractère physique tout à fait
inacceptables tous les élus quel que
soit leur bord politique d'ailleurs de
tous les partis politiques représentés
cela au nom des que l'état prenne ses
responsabilités et en effet que la
mairie de paris propose des lieux pour
pouvoir accueillir ces personnes dont la
réponse policière n'est pas la bonne
réponse s'agissant de toxicomanes qui
consomment du trac qui meurt en moins
d'un an leur consommation et qui
deviennent dépendants à 100% de cette
drogue au moment où ils prennent une
première dose
nous j'ai pris mes responsabilités en
effet parce que les riverains de la rue
riquet se tait tout à fait inacceptable
pour l'ordre public et j'ai fait
installer sur un lieu de la mairie de
paris en deçà du périphérique on ne peut
pas dire n'importe quoi square de la
villette où j'ai fait ériger un mur par
acquisition la mairie de paris qui ne
peut être que temporaire comme situation
sans riverains à immédiat pour pouvoir
trouver les heures et les jours qui
viennent une proposition ou des
compositions la mairie de paris la
présidente de région ile-de-france de
nous prêter des locaux de la région
ile-de-france confère à 100 de
désoxydation on attend le site qu'elle
nous propose demain matin le préfet de
la région ile de france et préfet de
police avec l'autorisation du premier
ministre va discuter avec la mairie de
paris bien évidemment et le ministère de
la santé puisque la rs un rôle
primordial en psy 4 ans médecin en
accompagnement et les autres élus et les
autres élus qui pourraient et vous savez
été conviés une réunion pour ceux qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet autour du
préfet d'île de france pour trouver des
sites dont je rappelle et il a été
rappelé dans la mairie de paris a écrit
au premier ministre pour expliquer
qu'elles proposeraient des lieux
municipaux et nous souhaitons avoir ses
yeux les plus rapidement possible pour
qu effectivement cela pour
qu'effectivement cela ne soit pas
continuelle sur le domaine public mais
je veux redire que derrière cela et
cette situation inacceptable et il ya
des êtres humains
la parole est cas le pr collègues
hussein bourgi pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine avait la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues la
journée internationale pour le droit à
l'avortement qui s'est déroulé hier a
été l'occasion de rappeler combien cette
liberté fondamentale pour les femmes
était loin d'être une réalité tant les
inégalités territoriales dans l'accès à
l'ivg et persiste en france nous le
savons tous et toutes le droit pour
chaque femme de disposer de son corps
reste précaire et fragile en france en
europe et dans le monde en france et la
question de l'allongement des délais de
douze à quatorze semaines qui restent
posées alors même qu'un texte a été voté
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale est soumis au débat au sénat
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
premier ministre quelles sont les
intentions du gouvernement en la matière
comptez vous inscrire ce sujet à
l'agenda parlementaire avant la fin du
quinquennat par ailleurs partout dans le
monde et singulièrement dans certains
pays de l'union européenne l'avortement
est pénalisé et l'accès à liv et j'ai
régulièrement entravée pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur les intentions de la france
à l'occasion de la présidence française
du conseil de l'union européenne je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole il faut
supporter des carreaux charge de
l'enfance et des familles sur plaque et
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bourgi
vous l'avez rappelé hier c'était la
journée mondiale du droit à l'avortement
que ce soit l'occasion à mon tour de
réaffirmé à cette occasion l'engagement
collectif du gouvernement de la majorité
et de l'ensemble des personnes sur ces
bancs à toujours défendre ce droit vous
l'avez rappelé droit qui est encore
bafoués dans un certain nombre de deux
pays proches proche de nous ce droit
c'est évidemment l'affirmation résolu du
droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps c'est un élément structurant de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et il faut le défendre sans relâche
jamais rien est acquis en la matière
alors vous avez évoqué l'extension du
délai légal de 12 à 14 semaines de
grossesse qui est une question majeure
évidemment pour les femmes qui sont
confrontés à une demande dit vg tardive
et qui ne résume pas vous le savez vous
l'avez d'ailleurs à évoquer dans votre
question à la question cruciale dans
notre pays de l'accès à l'ivg et g vous
avez rappelé vous rappelez part donc en
octobre dernier à l'occasion d'un débat
parlementaire sur le sujet le ministre
olivier veyrat avait saisi le conseil
consultatif national d'éthique qui a pu
rappeler dans son avis l'importance des
mesures de protection de prévention et
d'accompagnement des femmes il a
également
dit statut est considéré qu'il n'y avait
pas d'objection éthique à allonger le
délai d'accès ali vg de deux semaines la
position du ministre olivier ferrand
madame la sénatrice du gouvernement à ce
sujet a toujours été une position
d'humilité face à parfois
véhémence de certains commentaires ou
des bars qui n'était pas votre cas
monsieur le sénateur nous avons préféré
le sérieux des travaux de fond pour
identifier précisément les besoins et
les barrières à l'accès de livres et
gêne un certain nombre de femmes ça a
été un sujet crucial pendant la crise
sanitaire évidemment et vous le savez
nous avons pris un certain nombre de
mesures pour s'assurer que les femmes
auront accès un livre géant salle perdre
là et depuis plus globalement nous avons
mis en oeuvre un certain nombre de
mesures pour renforcer ce droit en
permettant la réalisation des ivg
instrumental ensemble de santé en
expérimentant la pratique des ivg
instrumentale par des sages-femmes en
milieu hospitalier en un clic en le
tiers payant intégral obligatoire aux
frais liés au web et enfin monsieur le
président je conclus en pérennisant
prochainement l'allongement des délais
de réalisation des ivg médicamenteuses
en ville de cinq à sept semaines de
grossesse je vous le redis encore tout
l'engagement du gouvernement à garantir
le droit à l'avortement et son accès
soit garanti pour toutes les femmes
monsieur bourges yves
monsieur le ministre je prends acte des
éléments de réponse que vous nous avez
apporté qui ne me satisfont pas tout à
fait vous avez fini par me convaincre
des propos de la véracité des propos
qu'a tenus une députée de votre majorité
présidentielle hier dans un grand
quotidien libération je la cite sur ce
sujet le premier ministre s'en fout le
président de la république n'a jamais
été fan de ces questions et castaner n'a
jamais poussé voilà ce qu'une de vos
députés a déclaré hier sous couvert de
l'anonymat dans libération alors
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
puisque vous êtes ici que vous écoutez
mon intervention je vais vous dire que
ce sujet est certes complexe il est
certes clivant en d'autres temps des
ministres qui siégeait à votre place ont
fait preuve de courage politique que ce
soit madame simone veil que ce soit
madame yvette audi et bien d'autres je
souhaite que ces femmes là vous inspirez
vous guide à l'avenir afin que le
courage politique soit au rendez vous
la parole
et à madame la présidente pascale gruny
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre de la santé quand je
regrette l'absence madame la ministre
hier 63 associations sos médecins
regroupant 1300 médecins se sont mis en
grève pour dénoncer une injustice depuis
15 ans le tarif de leurs visites à
domicile n'a pas évolué l'accord de
revalorisation signé en juillet dernier
par les syndicats de médecins libéraux
et l'assurance maladie ne profite qu'aux
médecins traitants excluant sos médecins
une provocation pourquoi mettre de côté
un service médical qui permet bien
souvent d'éviter l'engorgement des
services d'urgence et de pallier le
manque criant de médecins de ville
pourquoi exclure cm2 sein des
négociations simplement parce qu'ils
sont organisés sous forme associative
leur rôle est irremplaçable
la preuve à peine la grève était
l'annoncé avant-hier que les préfet
réquisitionné déjà sos médecins dans de
nombreuses villes de france monsieur le
ministre enfin madame la ministre nous
avons avec sos médecins un service qui
fonctionne et qui avec 3 millions de
visites à domicile par an a largement
fait ses preuves allez vous entendre
leurs revendications légitimes
ou au contraire y rester sourde et
prendre le risque de fragiliser encore
notre système de santé déjà bien mal en
point je vous remercie pour vous
répondre ma parole de la ministre
déléguée chargée de l'automobile à
bourguignon merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente pascale gruny vous
l'avez vous avez raison et soes médecin
est un acteur essentiel pour la
permanence des soins son engagement est
reconnu par tous dans un exercice
exigeant difficile et il honore
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
qui l'exercent
il permet aussi à des acteurs isolés que
nous connaissons bien des personnes
âgées ou contrainte en raison de leur
état de santé ou de perte d'autonomie de
ne pas se rendre dans un cabinet médical
vous le savez aussi peut-être une visite
trimestrielle des personnes âgées de 4
91 ans et plus à leur domicile est
essentiel aussi pour l'accompagnement au
long cours mais il s'agit là d'une
visite beaucoup plus longue quand on la
compare à dos intervention et elle ne
peut être réalisée elle que par le
médecin traitant
elle permet aussi d'assurer une
continuité des soins le conseil médical
cette visite complémentaire au bilan de
santé s'accompagne d'un entretien de
prévention ou de la mise à jour du
patient pour tous les autres patients
les visites à domicile sont rémunérés
exactement de la même façon pour tous
les médecins généralistes y compris ceux
de sos médecins dans le cadre des
négociations en cours sos médecins a été
reçu à plusieurs reprises pour
travailler au niveau de la cnam ils ont
été de nouveau reçus à la rentrée le
dialogue est là il est bien là et nous
souhaitons qu'il se poursuivent bien sûr
les médecins de cette association sont
par ailleurs concernées par la
revalorisation de la permanence des
soins ambulatoires qui fera l'objet d'un
texte réglementaire en octobre cette
revalorisation légitime et substantielle
et tu devrais je pense je l'espère
satisfaire sos médecins le gouvernement
est tout à fait sensibles à leurs
arguments 1 leur engagement par donc
oui merci dans tout et tout est correct
pour vous donc je ne sais pas pourquoi
ils font grève et je t'assure ils ont
prévu même pour noël donc je vous plains
déjà à l'avance les 9 et 10 juin à
toulouse le ministre avait promis une
revalorisation est justement que ça
allait arriver
c'est encore du du blabla de la com y'a
rien je rappelle qu'ils étaient en
première ligne lors de la crise
sanitaire qu'ils ont eu des confrères en
réanimation qu'ils ont perdu des
confrères je crois que sincèrement ils
ont besoin d'une vraie reconnaissance
est une reconnaissance financière et
ensuite beaucoup de jeunes se détournent
de sos médecins parce que justement il
n'y a pas cette cette reconnaissance
financière donc demain sos médecins va
disparaître alors sincèrement le système
de santé et va déjà très très mal je
pense qu'il faut vraiment que vous
fassiez une bonne action pour sos
médecins chez nous on a plus de médecin
traitant et aujourd'hui c'est la seule
réponse qu'on est donc merci de veiller
à leur situation
[Applaudissements]
la parole aux questeurs vincent
capo-canellas ce pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mise l'intérieur je
souhaite également aborder la suite de
thierry magnin l'installation de
consommateurs de crack
porte de la villette à paris ou lisière
des commune d'aubervilliers de pantin en
seine-saint-denis
bien sûr le groupement de consommateurs
de crack est un sujet malheureusement
anciens bien sûr c'est difficile bien
sûr c'est une problématique humaine bien
sûr il s'agit d'une addiction
il faut une prise en charge globale nous
le mesurons mais il n'en reste pas moins
que du strict point de vue de l'ordre
public cette décision est
incompréhensible
elle est pour les populations elle est
aussi parce qu'on a le sentiment que
l'on joue au bonneteau et qu' il n'y a
pas eu cette fois de coordination entre
la branche sécuritaire de l'état et la
branche qui fait l'accompagnement social
qui fait l'accompagnement éventuellement
psychiatrique et la rs pour de dire
d'autre part les élus locaux ont été mis
devant le fait accompli et évidemment
c'est côté parisien mais ça fait
longtemps que le périphérique n'est plus
une barrière ériger un mur sur quelques
mètres n'est pas la libye de toutes nos
difficultés et de certains de nos
renoncements le premier ministre est
venu il ya huit jours à bowling avec
force avec talent et je le sais avec
honnêteté et confiance dire que la
seine-saint-denis mérité un effort de la
république il a donné des gages les élus
l'ont cru et ils croient en la prophétie
biblique les habitants la seine saint
denis ont besoin plus que d'autres de
sérénité de tranquillité
d'accompagnement social et l'état la via
leur porte érigé en symbole qui est vécu
comme une provocation il y à cet après
midi vous savez une manifestation au
permis à pantin j'ai eu les deux maires
qui sont laissées à l'abandon qui ne
savent quoi répondre l'état local lui
même est désarmé et donc j'attends ici
que le gouvernement veuille bien nous
dire que cette situation ne va pas durer
évidemment il a fallu trouver une
solution qui ne peut être que
transitoire et que nous allons revenir
au coeur des politiques de l'état dans
l'accompagnement social pour trouver une
solution et retrouver une implantation
celle ci ne veut pas durer merci
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison j'ai été maire
d'une commune très populaire et je peux
comprendre ce que ressent la ville de
pantin où la ville d'aubervilliers même
si je le répète et on peut je sais que
vous êtes sans doute aller et elle est
encore ensemble ces prochaines heures ou
même cette nuit les policiers sont très
nombreuses corps de la villette dans le
rond point qui est juste à côté de ce
score de la villette et protège
justement le non passage en
seine-saint-denis et le mur qui a été
mis en place ce tunnel entre le square
de la villette et le département seine
saint denis a en effet été érigée par
réquisition de l'état dans la ville de
paris et n'est pas une solution pérenne
on en est tout à fait conscient j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre à votre collègue
tout à l'heure qu'il ne s'agissait que
d'une position d'attentes en attendant
des lieux médicalisés
vous avez tout à fait raison de dire
socialement accompagné de personnes
extrêmement malade et qui sont
extrêmement dépendants et nous avons
sorti d'un endroit où il y avait des
riverains immédiats
la rubrique est autour de briguer chacun
se souvient des reportages et des
articles peuvent être dans un endroit où
il ya à paris excusez-moi peu d'endroits
comme cela sans riverains une fois que
je lui ai dit ça évidemment ça ne peut
durer encore que quelques jours si je
dire quelques heures puisqu'il faut
absolument désormais que la ville de
paris et l'état je sais par
l'intermédiaire du préfet de région où
la région ile de france puisqu'un
pécresse va nous faire des propositions
de lieux dans les locaux de la région
ile de france on sera très heureux de
pouvoir accompagner cela bien évidemment
des endroits on peut mettre que ces
personnes qui sont gravement malades je
sais que l' ars d'île de france mais
très moyen en psy 4 ans psychologue en
accompagnant médicaux et sociaux de ces
personnes et ainsi nous pourrons
évidemment mettre fin à cette occupation
du score de david est et rassurer ainsi
légitimement les élusates annie je veux
dire que le préfet de police la
préfecture de police a pris sur ma
demande contact avec les maires je conte
rend leurs difficultés leur désarroi
leur doutes je les partage je veux vous
dire que nous mettons des moyens
policiers pour les empêcher et
évidemment de passer un sony ou de
retourner rue riquet je veux redire que
c'est pas une réponse policière qu'il
faut mais bien une réponse sanitaire à
ce drame
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jean bart gwaii pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
votre prédécesseur a décrété la
limitation à 80 km heure sur les routes
départementales au 1er juillet 2018 le
coût de cette opération est estimé à 12
millions d'euros
dix-huit mois plus tard après de vives
contestations et pour ne pas se dédire
la loi d'orientation des mobilités
autorisé le départ pour revenir à 90 sur
le réseau routier ainsi près de 40
départements hors établis ou sont en
cours de rétablir le 90 km/heure de
manière volontaire et après concertation
avec les élus locaux or les routes
nationales dans ces départements sont
restés à 80 km/heure
cette incohérence provoque
l'incompréhension des automobilistes qui
vivent l'aberration consistant à rouler
à 80 sur des routes nationales il ya 90
sur les routes départementales
il est impératif dans un objectif de
sécurité
d'harmoniser la vitesse autorisée sur la
continuité du réseau routier
je me doute que vous allez me démontrer
en interprétant et en manipulant les
chiffres une baisse de la mortalité sur
les routes et cela a sans surprise après
dix-huit mois de confinement de la même
façon de la même façon que rien ne
démontre une baisse de la mortalité avec
le 80 sur les routes départementales
rien ne démontre que le retour aux 90 a
provoqué de hausse de la mortalité
alors monsieur le premier ministre face
à cette situation absurde allez-vous
décrété un retour aux 90 sur les routes
nationales à l'instar des présidents de
départements qui ont pris leurs
responsabilités
monsieur premier nice mini ce pardon
allez vous remettre sur nos routes
françaises un peu de cohérence de
logique et de bon sens
vous réponde à paroles et aux villes de
l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs gg la joie et
l'honneur de vous répondre sur cette
question
37 départements trente sept départements
hauts saisi la main qui est celle de la
décentralisation de fixer sur une
portion de la route qui leur appartenait
le passage à 80 et qu'être à 2 80 à 90
37 c'est à dire un tiers des
départements français
nous constatons d'ailleurs que le procès
ce qui l'amène années l'état a refusé
une seule les demandes de ses 37
départements après est une tactique
d'anthologie et après mise en place de
voirie ou de personnalisation il
appartient au département dans le
respect le plus strict me semble-t-il du
principe de décentralisation de fixer
dans les compétences qu'ils souhaitent
fixer mais en ce qui concerne l'état et
j'ai eu l'occasion de répondre par
lettre au département et aux élus qui
m'interrogeait nous garderons la
position qui a été celle de la sécurité
routière et du premier ministre de
l'époque li bruce actuelle à 80
kilomètres à l'heure
monsieur boyer
mais dommage monsieur le ministre que
vous vous enfermez dans vos chiffres et
dans la situation actuelle que vous
n'écoutiez pas ces français
automobilistes qui souhaitent tout
simplement de la sécurité bien sûr mais
qui souhaitent aussi de la cohérence et
du bon sens son hôte merci
à part les cas de notre collègue michel
meunier pour le gros socialistes
écologistes et républicains la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire chargé
des personnes handicapées ou plutôt au
ministre des comptes publics tant il est
évident que ce gouvernement répond à la
préoccupation des personnes en situation
de handicap de manière
budgétaire logique comptable je veux
évoquer ici madame la ministre le mode
de calcul de l'allocation adulte
handicapé pour les personnes vivant en
couple
903 euros par mois c'est bien souvent le
seul revenu que perçoivent c'est un
million deux cent mille allocataires
vivant seul dans sept à huit cas sur dix
pour les autres en couple le montant de
l'allocation dépend des revenus du ou de
la partenaire
les personnes concernées et les
associations du secteur du handicap ont
longtemps dénoncé ce calcul différentiel
l'hiver dernier l'assemblée nationale a
adopté contre toute attente une
proposition de loi qui individualise
l'allocation adulte handicapé un progrès
engagés et ce malgré l'avis de contre du
gouvernement il y a quelques mois le
sénat ici a également voté pour la dea
conjugale isation nos raisons sont
simples c'est une entrave à l'autonomie
financière pour les personnes qui
subissent déjà des entraves à leur
autonomie c'est une assignation à
dépendre économiquement du conjoint et 7
conjugale isation de la hache et perfide
pour les femmes puisqu'elles enferme les
femmes handicapées dans leur foyer où
elles risquent deux à six fois plus que
les femmes valide de subir des violences
sexuelles
pourtant en juin l'assemblée a instauré
un mécanisme d'abattement forfaitaires
sur les revenus du conjoint pris en
compte le projet de loi de finances pour
2022 dévoilé la semaine dernière a
précisé les modalités de cet abattement
loin de simplifier le calcul il
complique hi-fi encore la hache madame
la ministre quand allez-vous mettre
enfin en place ce qu'attendent depuis
très longtemps
les personnes handicapées pour vous
répondre je ne la parole à
la sq autorités en charge des personnes
handicapées la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
personnes en situation d'handicap est
une priorité du gouvernement permettez
moi de rappeler les droits que nous
avons vers droit de vote droit de
parentalité droit au logement droit à
vie alors oui en effet je n'ai pas
souscrit à la mesure de des conjugale
isation car la hache est une aide
sociale construite comme tous les autres
minima sociaux et si vous le croyez pas
pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas fait quand
vous étiez à ce moment là aux manettes
au gouvernement il est donc normal de
prendre en compte les revenus du
conjoint
la décongélation aurait eu pour effet de
favoriser les couples plus aisés cela
aussi c'est contraire à nos valeurs me
semble-t-il et de créer ainsi une
exception pour les personnes en
situation de handicap je rappelle que
nous avons augmenté l'âge de cent euros
depuis 2010 est c'est à dire porter à
900 euros pour plus de 1 million de
personnes en situation de handicap et
c'est plus besoin de repasser par là
même des parce que maintenant ce sont
des droits à vie nous sommes le premier
gouvernement à l'avoir fait alors j'ai
entendu les personnes en situation de
handicap je les ai entendus et
concrètement j'ai porté un amendement
qui est redistributif beaucoup plus que
le calcul actuel c'est 5000 euros
d'abattement qui vont permettre à quoi
tout simplement à plus de 120 mille
ménages qui verront ainsi leurs haches
augmenté pour un gain moyen de 110 euros
par mois pouvant aller jusqu'à 100 86
euros et s'être voorn ne fera aucun
perdant alors que ce que vous proposiez
c'était 44 mille ménages qui travaillent
qui aurait perdu alors non madame la
sénatrice nous avons pris cet engagement
eh bien il est inscrit il est inscrit
tout simplement dans l'article 43 parce
que nous voulons des droits réels qui
puissent s'appliquer dès le 1er janvier
2022 c'est comme ça que nous travaillons
alors si vous voulez vraiment là des
conjugale isation et l'individualisation
ne fait pas des personnes handicapées
des citoyens à part et travaillons sur
l'ensemble de l'individualisation
pourquoi pas
merci la parole est à notre collègue
bruno rangement pour le groupe des
républicains
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
monsieur le ministre
ces dernières années le droit à
l'environnement a été fortement étoffé
et les lois sur la gestion de l'eau se
sont multipliés si nul ne conteste le
bien fondé de ces réglementations force
est de constater qu'elles deviennent de
plus en plus complexes et étendu le
secteur agricole doit régulièrement
s'adapter dans le contexte difficile que
vous connaissez une des dernières
modifications en la matière concerne la
révision de la carte des zones
vulnérables aux nitrates par exemple
pour mon départements l'allier plus de
80 communes ont été nouvellement intégré
cette réforme a un impact considérable
puisque tout agriculteur ayant une
partie de son exploitation en zone
vulnérable doit mettre en oeuvre une
série de démarches nouvelle
l'arrêté de classification des communes
est paru le 30 août 2021 pour une
application dès le 1er septembre 2021 de
nombreux agriculteurs se retrouvent
ainsi pris de court est dans
l'obligation d'engager des changements
dans un délai trop bref certes des
échéances plus lointaines ont été
accordées pour la mise aux normes des
bâtiments
cependant la progressivité des
obligations entraîne une véritable
confusion au sein du monde agricole qui
doit faire déjà faire face à de
nombreuses formalités administratives
aussi en raison du délai très court
imposé pour faire preuve de la plus
grande clarté il serait souhaitable de
ne retenir qu'une seule date
d'application pour la totalité de ces
mesures laissant le temps aux
agriculteurs de se préparer monsieur le
ministre j'espère que vous serez
sensible et entendrez la voix de toute
une profession qui est volontaire pour
se réformer mais auquel l'impossible
n'est pas tenue je vous remercie la
parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation
je suis de normandie vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur rejouant je crois
que vous savez que j'entends avec la la
plus grande attention la voie du monde
agricole à qui nous devons tant sur la
question de cette directive nitrates que
nous connaissons depuis maintenant fort
longtemps on sait c'est partagé par tous
qu'il ya un enjeu de qualité de l'eau et
chacun souhaite améliorer la qualité de
l'eau mais pour répondre à votre
préoccupation qui est tout à fait
légitime je voudrais apporter trois
éléments de réponse le premier c'est que
nous avons un enjeu de cartographie cet
enjeu de cartographie vous l'avez très
bien dit dans votre département il peut
impliquer de qualifier de nouvelles
zones soumises à cette directive
nitrates je crois pouvoir dire qu'on a
fait un gros travail de concertation
même un énorme travail de concertation
qui a débuté de mémoire en octobre 2010
qui a fait l'objet d'un vrai travail
scientifique c'est à dire qu'on a reçus
une première copie à laquelle on a dit
non il y a des failles dedans on a revu
cette copie on a réduit
significativement d'ailleurs le nombre
de communes concernées se basant sur la
raison et la science comme j'aime le
dire et aujourd'hui cette cartographie
est là était terminé après on a un
deuxième échelon qui est la question du
cadre national le fameux plan national
nitrates et ce cadre national avec le
même souci de concertation l'après fiq
la profession nous a demandé et d'autres
d'ailleurs de pouvoir décaler sa mise en
oeuvre non pas au 1er septembre 21 mai
au 1er septembre 22 et nous avons accédé
à cette demande pour avoir le temps de
d'accompagner de se mobiliser dans
l'accompagnement et ceci d'ailleurs mon
troisième élément de réponse à cet enjeu
collectif de la qualité de l'eau nous
devons l'accompagnement pour nos
agriculteurs
c'est d'abord l'accompagnement des
agences de l'eau c'est l'accompagnement
des régions parce que beaucoup des
financements peuvent passer par le
truchement des régions et vous le savez
par exemple dans votre belle jouons un
appel famille les appels à projets ont
d'ores et déjà été lancés sur les
diagnostics et l'accompagnement de
l'état évidemment voilà l'ensemble de la
cartographie de ce que nous faisons
l'ensemble de la dynamique que nous
faisons avec ce souci soyez en certain
monsieur le sénateur d'accompagner nos
agriculteurs dans ce défi un de plus
qu'on leur demande de réaliser je vous
remercie merci la parole et à notre
collègue pierre antoine lévy pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la santé monsieur le
ministre la loi relative à la gestion de
la crise sanitaire d'août dernier a
prévu qu'à partir du 15 septembre les
professionnels médicaux et paramédicaux
devaient être vaccinés pour pouvoir
continuer d'exercer le texte prévoit que
ceux qui n'ont pas encore reçu une
première dose doivent être suspendues
jusqu'au 15 octobre ceux qui ont reçu
une dose doivent avoir terminé leur
parcours vaccinale à cette même date
cette mesure apparaît inapplicable la
preuve alors qu'aucun septembre trois
cent mille soignant était encore
réfractaires seuls 3000 suspension
auraient été prononcés soit 1% quid des
99 autres évidemment tous ces soignants
ne peuvent pas être suspendue car cela
mettrait à mal l'ensemble de notre
système de santé même avec la suspension
d'environ 3000 praticiens la continuité
des soins commence à ne plus être
assurés dans nos très nombreux endroits
sur le territoire
d'autant que nombre de professionnels de
santé ont démissionné dans la période
récente par lassitude ou épuisement
monsieur le ministre loin de moi le fait
de me poser en donneur de leçons en
cette période je suis d'ailleurs à titre
personnel favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants uniquement
mais force est de constater que les
mesures prises ne fonctionne pas et pire
elles sont contre-productives dans nos
hôpitaux quelques exemples le chat chu
de nice doit faire face avec 450 agents
- l'hôpital de montélimar a été obligé
de déprogrammer des interventions avant
même la date du 15 septembre le
composent pitallier de la région de
mulhouse sud alsace a été obligé de
déclencher le plan blanc non pas pour
cause d'un pic épidémique mais par
manque de soignants dès lors monsieur le
ministre allez vous poursuivre ce bras
de fer longtemps combien avez-vous
prononcé de nouvelles suspensions depuis
le 15 septembre et surtout que se
passera-t-il après le 15 octobre mais
suspendu vont-ils être réintégrés ou mis
à pied signer dié puisque la loi
interdit de les licencier je vous
remercie pour vos réponses vous répondre
la parole est tout sauf quelqu'un d'état
chargé de l'emploi ou de la famille je
takeda part merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur lévy je
vous remercie de ne pas vous poser en
donneur de leçons mais veillons s'il
vous plaît les uns et les autres à ne
pas propager de fausses informations à
nos concitoyens
je vous rappeler que 50 millions de
français ont reçu une première dose que
48 millions de nos concitoyens on compte
un schéma vaccinal complet les quelques
8 millions qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés encore 8 millions de nos
concitoyens qui n'ont pas encore reçu
d'injection parmi ceux qui sont
éligibles les démarches d'aller vers se
poursuivre tout cela va être facilitée
par la mise à disposition
dans les pharmacies du vaccin pfizer à
compter du 1er octobre prochain et
concernant les professionnels de santé
plus particulièrement parce que c'est
l'objet de votre question rappeler enfin
vous l'avez dit que l'obligation de
vacciner vaccination fixé par la loi est
entrée en vigueur le 15 septembre tout
en laissant professionnel jusqu'au 15
octobre ils ont déjà reçu une première
dose de vaccin avec pour logic
évidemment de protéger les soignants
évidemment de protéger les salariés des
établissements évidemment de protéger
les malades les derniers chiffres dont
nous disposons indiquent que tous les
secteurs d'exercice dépasse les 93 % de
personnel vacciner
ce chiffre atteint 96% dans les
établissements médico sociaux
les suspensions prononcées ne concerne
que 0,7 pour cent de l'ensemble des
personnels et contrairement à ce que
certains avaient voulu faire croire ce
que j'ai un peut déceler dans vos propos
il n'y a pas eu de rupture dans la
continuité des soins alors ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu quelques
difficultés locales elles ont tout de
suite été identifiés remontée prise en
charge par les agences régionales de
santé suivi de très près par le
ministère des solidarités de la santé on
remarque par ailleurs que depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de cette obligation
à niveau de vaccination a progressé
rapidement ce qui est un élément de
réponse à votre question je tiens à
saluer donc l'implication de toutes les
équipes de direction qui ont accompagné
les agents salué les agents par la même
occasion et pour répondre à votre
dernière question dire qu'effectivement
évidemment pour conclure qu'une
suspension n'est pas définitive et que
le message derrière chaque décision est
claire et simple vaccinez vous
merci monsieur lévi vous avez quelques
secondes
oui monsieur milices me parlait des
français vaccinés je connais
effectivement le chiffre moi je vous
parlais des soignants le chiffre que je
vous ai donné tous les chiffres sont
parfaitement vérifier je n'ai jamais dit
qu'il y avait une rupture deux dans le
système de santé j'ai dit qu'ils avaient
de grandes difficultés dans plusieurs
territoires vous pouvez vérifier cette
eau tendre et merci on vous remercie
madame monsieur lui je devrais y saluer
la dernière séance c'est pas le cinéma
de robert del picchia vice président de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense sénateur depuis 1988 et
représentant les français établis hors
de france
[Applaudissements]
nos prochaines questions d'actualité
auront lieu le 6 octobre 15h la séance
est suspendue
elle sera reprise à 16h40 pour la suite
du projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée pour la confiance
dans l'institution judiciaire autre
séance est suspendue
voilà donc pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
séance notamment marqué par cet hommage
rendu par gérard larcher partout le
sénat la mémoire de maxime blasco maxime
blasco ce soldat français tué vendredi
dernier au mali ce 52e soldat français
tué au sahel depuis 2013 pour en parler
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau david assouline bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur socialiste de paris à
côté de vous jean françois rapin bonjour
sénateurs les républicains du pas de
calais et en face de vous françois
patriat son joueur r dépit la république
en marche de la côte d'or alors on va
refaire en toute la séance avec vous
mais peut-être quelques mots sur cet
hommage rendu par gérard larcher et le
sénat à ce soldat tragiquement tués la
semaine dernière david assouline c'est
important de rendre hommage comme ça
c'est soldats qu'on perd de plus en plus
régulièrement maintenant dans des
opérations à l'extérieur vous pouvez
bien sûr c'est ce sont les hommages les
plus émouvants parce qu'il s'agit de
ceux qui se battent pour nous pour la
france pour la sécurité de chacun
d'entre nous ça se passe des fois sur le
territoire métropolitain français et des
fois ça se passe en opérations
extérieures
loin de chez nous mais c'est le même
combat coûte le terrorisme islamiste et
et
on sait très bien que que c'est un coup
à extérieures et intérieures
qu'il faut mener sur tous les fronts et
je trouve qu'en plus ça nous permet de
de connaître ceux qui sont engagés là
bas de mettre un visage mais oui parce
que bon voilà on a des soldats on sait
qu'on a quelques milliers de soldats ici
ou là et
voilà c'est le tous les témoignages qui
raconte l'héroïsme et le courage ce
soldat qui s'était déjà manifesté à
d'autres moments
c'est ses besoins et la nation en bois
vraiment elles seront assemblées à ce
moment là on va continuer d'en parler
dans quelques instants mais j'aimerais
tout de suite qu'on retrouve aux rêves
et alain qui dans l'hémicycle audrey
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu vous en
dehors de cet hommage tout ce que vous
avez retenu de cette séance d'actualité
alors parmi et toutes les questions qui
ont été posées goût au gouvernement il y
en a une qui concerne le quotidien des
français la hausse du prix des énergies
gaz et électricité que peut faire le
gouvernement pour aider les ménages
français alors les sénateurs ont salué
la mise en place d'un chèque
exceptionnelle de 100 euros pour les
ménages les plus précaires mais ils ont
aussi demandé plus au gouvernement
notamment concernant la tva écoutez la
question posée à bérenger rabat la
secrétaire d etat chargé de la
biodiversité
entendez vous reconnaître l'énergie
comme un bien de première nécessité en
baissant la tva sur le gaz et sur
l'électricité alors pas de réponse de la
secrétaire d'état sur la tva sur le fait
de baisser la tva en revanche elle a
fait une petite annonce elle a dit que
des mesures seraient mises en place dans
les prochains jours des mesures
exceptionnelles supplémentaires pour
aider les ménages français autre sujet
brûlant qui a donné lieu à une passe
d'armes au sénat tout à l'heure vous
l'avez sûrement vu un la construction
d'un mur entre paris et la seine saint
denis pour bloquer une centaine de
toxicomanes
le sénateur thierry maignan nouveaux
sénateurs qui remplace philippe dallier
sénateur de seine saint denis en a
profité pour poser la première question
au gouvernement ça a donné lieu à une
passe d'armes avec le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin écoutait
tout de suite cet échange on a rétabli
la double peine en seine-saint-denis
je m'explique à travers la décision de
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur de
déplacer les toxicomanes du jardin
d'eole vers la seine-saint-denis
et d'autre part les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis subissent la politique
menée par la mairie de paris qui tend de
plus en plus souvent à transférer ses
problèmes vers les départements
limitrophes et donc également la seine
saint denis
paris déverse vers la banlieue et vers
la seine saint denis aujourd'hui pantin
aubervilliers un certain nombre de ces
de ces problèmes et je le dis avec
fermeté la seine saint denis ne peut pas
devenir le dépotoir de parlons de femmes
d'hommes et d'enfants et non pas de
déchets d'ordures ou d'immondices et
j'ai fait installer sur un lieu de la
mairie de paris en deçà du périphérique
on ne peut pas dire n'importe quoi
square de la villette où j'ai fait
ériger un mur par acquisition la mairie
de paris qu'il peut être que temporaire
comme situation sans aux riverains à
immédiat pour pouvoir trouver les heures
et les jours qui viennent une
proposition au des propositions de la
mairie de paris vous l'avez entendu une
mesure temporaire d'après le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin qui a
annoncé se concerter demain avec la rs
d'île de france et avec la mairie de
paris pour trouver des lieux pour
pouvoir mettre en place la
désintoxication de ces personnes merci
beaucoup audrey monsieur patriat peut
être une réaction à cette affaire du
crack qui empoisonnent un peu les
relations entre la mairie de paris et le
gouvernement de plus en plus maintenant
franchement je crois qu'il faut sortir
de ses divisions inutiles entre paris la
banlieue l'île de france c'est l'île de
france qui connaît des problèmes
généraux plus que chacun de tenter de
résoudre d'abord c'est un problème de
collectivités c'est pas un problème de
l'état a priori ce que fait l'état
aujourd'hui ils essayent avec les
colites études avec les collectivités de
trouver une solution
ça a été bien dit une solution
temporaire on le dit depuis le début
qu'il s'agit pas de déplacer des gens de
déporter des gens mais c'est ce qu'on
fait
on le fait là parce qu'il ya un espace
qui s'y prête parce qu'il ya une
possibilité d'avoir des gens qui sont en
dehors de toute continuité autour de
pouvoir être protégés soigner en
attendant que les collectivités ans elle
trouve que là la région que la ville que
l'état y participe pour trouver un lieu
donc vous avez compris qu'il ya urgence
les urgences parce que la proximité les
agressions les viols ou douala si le
gouvernement ne faisait rien parce que
les collectivités ne s'entendent pas on
lui reprocherait le gouvernement le fait
il trouve momentanément un lieu plus
adapté pour pouvoir aller mettre à
l'abri votre à l'abri des agressions
extérieures de l'agression et de trouver
et de trouver dans le temps les jours et
dans les semaines qui viennent et
solutions durables dont je pense que
c'est ce qu'aia sont inutiles de ce
qu'on voyait comme ça c'est pas ça qui
fait avancer le schmilblick c'est pas ça
qui fait avancer la cause c'est de la
petite fille vous dites quoi c'est un
peu ce que je dis mais sur a peint sur
cette question d'aider des toxicomanes
c'est pas une question juste franco
français c'est pas une question
uniquement parisienne passant le cap de
la rhétorique politique effectivement
mais là où je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec monsieur patriat c'est
qu'ils reportent sur finalement les
collectivités en disant c'est pas un
problème de l'état c'est un problème des
collectivités non moi je suis pas
d'accord c'est un problème de l'état
rené bon bien sûr on est réellement
aussi dans un problème de sécurité
publique on l'a entendu dans les
différents propos d'ailleurs même le
ministre dit attention il ya des hommes
des femmes derrière tout ça oui à des
hommes des femmes qui habitent dans ces
territoires et qui peuvent eux-mêmes
souffrir de ceux de ce désagrément
majeur est donc le vrai problème c'est
celui initial qui est celui des dealers
et d'ailleurs les propos les plus
importants dans la question de mon
collègue c'est la fin où ils image une
chanson de gainsbourg en disant voilà
ces ladies les dealers le trafic donc à
partir du moment où on met un pansement
sur une jambe de bois en disant
finalement on déplace le problème
mais ailleurs après c'est aux
collectivités de se débrouiller on n'est
pas dans son rôle et les tâches
de sécurité donc le problème c'est les
dealers après c'est la santé publique
parce que le cra aquitain est un état
vrais sujets sains le ministre l'a
rappelé et il a raison il n'a pas menti
une prise c'est 100% de ses 100 %
d'addiction immédiatement donc
effectivement il ya un problème de santé
publique mais à l'origine un problème
sécuritaire et un problème de thé de
dépistage de débusquage de ce trafic
david assouline élus de paris sur cette
question oui le premier problème c'est
que on laisse
pas pas seulement des malades sont sans
venir à leur secours on les livre parce
que on accepte qu'un marché à ciel
ouvert qu'on déplace de temps en temps
de deals de crack si y'avait pas l'offre
ben peut-être que certains seraient
amenés à chercher des solutions
médicales
mais à partir du moment où c'est à ciel
ouvert il ya un problème donc un
problème la responsabilité alors dans la
mairie dans de l'or ziani delgo
attendait à la nommer je vais vous dire
il ya un problème donc de sécurité
publique sécurité publique c'est l'état
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et donc ça
fait des mois et des mois qu'on demande
à l'état non pas devenir évacué pour
leur porter sur un autre endroit est
très souvent avant ils nous disent voilà
ils vont aller là où qu'ils savent en
plus où ils vont aller une fois que les
habitants sont exaspérés à tel endroit
mais de chercher et nous avons écrit
depuis madame hidalgo sa responsabilité
vous avez des réponses a écrit depuis
longtemps aux ministres et au premier
ministre pour demander qu'il y ait des
lieux et pour demander d'agréer des
lieux qu'on proposait parce que de toute
façon on peut les ouvrir nous-mêmes que
si l'état les agrée bon alors il ya eu
une réponse positive là
monsieur jean castex en disant d'accord
on demande maintenant à l'état de mettre
la main aussi sur les lieux mêmes parce
que l'état à paris a beaucoup de terrain
on pourrait même construire dans des
préfabriqués et c'est pour avoir des
lieux médicalisés
parce que vous savez qu'à paris il n'y a
pas tellement de locaux disponibles 1
via les terrains sncf il ya les terrains
de l'ap-hp des hôpitaux etc il ya pas
mal de terrain en l'état peut venir en
aide mais c'est le deuxième problème
c'est un problème de santé publique
en effet c'est à dire que il faut pas
affoler non plus les populations il
s'agit de gens malades à soigner ceux
qui sont là un problème de trafic il
faut le réprimer faut être impitoyable
il ya un problème de santé publique
parce que ce qui rend dans cette
addiction il faut absolument les soigner
c'est notre devoir et voilà dans quel
domaine où ville de paris on peut et
madame hidalgo veut faire et le propose
contre tous ceux qui agitent les peurs
et qui font uniquement du sécuritaire
sur l'histoire pour qu' il y ait des
lieux on en a proposé plusieurs et on en
cherche nôtres pour soigner comme on l'a
fait dans le 10e arrondissement et c est
très souvent ça je suis content de vos
propos responsables parce que très
souvent quand on ouvre un lieu comme
dans le 10e arrondissement on l'avait
fait pas loin de la gare du nord et bien
la droite ont fait un thème de campagne
démagogique en disant bien emmener les
drogués la
ja peur braves gens etc or il faut bien
les soigner dans des endroits il faut
bien trouver ces endroits il est 16h30
de à cet instant précis un hommage est
rendu aux invalides au sergent maxime
blasco le sergent qui a été tué vendredi
dernier dans l'opération barkan au sel
un hommage a été rendu
aujourd'hui au sénat page est relâché on
va peut-être les goûters et ensuite jour
ferait réagir à nouveau sur sur le mali
est donc sur cette nouvelle mort d'un
soldat français en opérations
extérieures l'écouté
au nom du sénat tout entier je veux
saluer le courage l'abnégation de ce
soldat mort pour la france en luttant
contre le terrorisme djihadiste au sahel
en notre nom à tous je veux assurer sa
famille
de notre profonde compassion et leur
présenter nos condoléances les plus
attristées
sa carrière vue militaire fut marquée
par de multiples actes héroïques décoré
par le président de la république de la
médaille militaire il fut avant tout un
exemple à la fois de courage et
d'humilité
fait partie de ces hommes dont il ne
faut pas attendre qu'il soit mort au
champ d'honneur pour prendre conscience
qu'ils sont grands alors cette mort elle
intervient dans un contexte un peu
partie un peu particulier intervient à
un moment où la france elle entame une
réorganisation une ré articulations le
gouvernement veut pas parler de
désengagement au mali est ce que selon
vous françois patriat cette mort valide
le calendrier et la méthode du
gouvernement au mali pour ce difficile à
répondre comme ça à cette question je
reviens à l'instant sur le match qui est
rendu aujourd'hui c'est ce que disait
malraux malraux disait il est des
moments où l'histoire à 1 1 la france un
visage disait ça et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui en particulier dit c'est
ça le jour d'entrée de jean moulin au
panthéon donc moi je note aussi un
hommage qui est rendu aujourd'hui pour
rappeler à ceux qui disent nord pour
rien que ça n'est pas vrai ce soldat
héroïque qui a déjà des preuves de
bravoure extraordinaire plusieurs
éléments contre le terrorisme tout à
l'heure david assouline l'a dit donc on
n'est pas mort pour rien il est allé
là-bas pour lutter contre ceux qui
aujourd'hui veulent instaurer le
terrorisme non seulement dans le sahel
mais chez nous mais sur sa répondu
calendrier tout à l'heure florence parly
a très bien répondu
la france ne quitte pas
ference parler ensuite je vous fait
réagir mais coûte tout de suite d'un
ministre des armées
ayez une contre vérité non la france ne
se désengage pas du mali je leur dis
clairement quand on a des milliers de
soldats sur place comme c'est notre cas
aujourd'hui
lorsque on multiplie les opérations de
contre terrorisme avec des succès
tactiques notable lorsque comme nous
venons de le faire nous déployons nos
nouveaux blindés griffon abarkan au
sahel vous conviendrez avec moi que ce
n'est pas l'attitude d'un pays qui s'en
va non la france ne se désengage pas
hors du mali faisait d'accord avec ce
que dit france que j'entends bien
d'ailleurs elle rappelle qu'il ya
quelques jours seulement un chef
ben là bas terroriste a été abattu un
des chefs principaux a été abattu est
décédé on l'a dit on remet aujourd'hui
des moyens matériels ce que la france
fait au mali aujourd'hui elle s'y est
beaucoup plus âgée souvenez vous quand
françois hollande est allé là bas qui a
été saluée au mali tout ce que la france
a fait là bas et la france ne peut pas
continuer seul seuls aujourd'hui dans
cette zone sahel aujourd'hui assurer la
sécurité et à lutter contre le
terrorisme le terrorisme il frappa pas
seulement la france demain après
l'italie l'allemagne l'espagne et
d'autres pays pour vous demander
aujourd'hui je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
france reste là bas sous une forme qui
est sans doute performante plus nouvelle
parce que on a bien vu que c'est
difficile de faire travailler les
troupes les troupes maliennes de les
faire agir on sait bien que ces combines
afghanistan là que la corruption tout
est installé là bas et qui permet pas de
remplir totalement la mission dont je
pense que la france a raison aujourd'hui
de se donner les moyens de continuer de
lutter contre le terrorisme
d'une façon qu'il permettra d'être
efficace mais aussi d'appeler d'autres
autour de nous à venir nous aider à
lutter contre ce fléau jean françois
rapin ce que les pays les autres pays
européens en font assez pour nous aider
notamment au mali au sel avant de
répondre à votre question bien sûr moi
je m'associe à tous les propos qui ont
été portés mais portait depuis fine dans
le monde nombreuses années sur sur tous
ces militaires qui sont décédés c'est en
le rappelant et finalement c'est une
forme de pédagogie pour dire il faut il
faut absolument pas oublier ce qui se
passe là bas parce qu'on est loin de
tout ça et nos concitoyens sont pas
forcément sensible à cette question
aujourd'hui
moi ce que je constate et au travers les
derniers propos c'est que 1 les propos
du premier ministre malien d'un
gouvernement rassemblement transitoires
sont inacceptables selon lui la france a
abandonné le mali en plein vol il a
déclaré sa venue c'est complètement
inacceptable parce que la france y est
quand même depuis 2014 avec park and mai
2013 déjà 2012 et d'autres opérations
extérieures préalablement et on ya
laissé beaucoup de soldats en tout cas
beaucoup de beaucoup de vies alors sur
l'europe il ya un sujet qui émergent en
ce moment qui émerge à l'issue
d'ailleurs aussi de des questions
pandémique etc c'est la question de
l'autonomie stratégique et de
l'autonomie aussi de défense et on va
mettre sur la table je pense ces sujets
de possibilité de défense
64 ça fait 80 ans qu'on en parle mais ça
n'a jamais été possible est plus que
jamais on va le voir et la france devra
le dire peut-être pendant sa présidence
française bathie seras jambes
l'essentiel il sera essentiel de
rappeler à nos congénères européens que
la france ne peut pas être seul sur ses
dispositions on peut pas envoyer nos
soldats comme de la chair à canon au nom
de la défense européenne c'est sûr parce
que les autres aussi participer on est
on est aujourd'hui depuis que les
anglais sont sortis de l'union
européenne les larmes et la mieux
équipée la mieux formée mais on a aussi
besoin de forces et de troupes
complémentaire est en tout cas d'une
solidarité européenne alors il ya des
forces paramilitaires rue saint qui
devrait qui pourrait intervenir et
prendre la place de la france au mali en
tout cas des négociations avec les
autorités maliennes actuellement si
c'est le cas si des mercenaires russes
du groupe wagner c'est le nom qui est
utilisé pour évoquer ces mercenaires
qui intervient notamment en libye si ces
mercenaires remplace la france qu'est ce
qu'on fait notamment dans le nord du
pays est ce qu'il faut rompre le contact
et rentrer les les échanges avec les
autorités maliennes
c'est absolument inadmissible si cette
chose était confirmée je veux pas le
croire parce que ce serait une rupture
de touche qui constitue la confiance et
les accords avec la france mais au delà
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
bien sûr que la france doit continuer à
remplir sa mission elle le fait pour le
peuple malien elle le fait pour
l'ensemble des européens faut pas
oublier pour les français
et
j'espère que n'est pas du tout envisagé
même de façon échelonnée un retrait qui
s'apparenterait à celui des engagements
tous les cas qui est humain d'un déni ce
temps la ministre a été clair je veux la
croire mais se pose une vraie question
que vous avez posé qui est que l'europe
doit prendre ses responsabilités la
question de l'europe de la défense se
pose dans plusieurs domaines s'est posé
au monde aghanistan elle se pose
globalement parce que les états unis eau
ou dessiner quand même depuis quelques
années de changer leur politique leur
relation l'otan même qu'elle apporte à
leur offre bon voilà il ya un sujet il
ya un gros différend on n'est plus dans
la même situation qu'avant et il faut
absolument maintenant que l'europe bois
par ses propres moyens comment que
comment elle sonnait faux c'est juste
une phrase très attention avec le mali
ne pas considérer que la façon de les
aider à lutter contre le terrorisme
c'est uniquement une question militaire
m'a dit ça passe par là mais il faut
voir comment parce que les dés on sait
très bien que ces théories sortent de
leur isolement quotidien am sociales
économiques etc il faut voir et ne pas
lésiner sur les moyens pour aider ces
pays à se développer ce pays à se
développer alors il faut qu'on avance on
a retrouvé tout de suite quand un calme
et en salle des conférences quentin qui
est avec la sénatrice dominique vais
rien
oui dominique verrien bonjour sénatrice
centriste de l'yonne merci de farés
hamiti répondre aux questions publiques
sanaa un mot d'abord sur et bien
l'émotion en début de séance lorsque cet
hommage a été rendu au nom du sénat par
gérard larcher qu'est ce que ça vous a
inspiré
beaucoup d'émotion comme vous le disiez
effectivement puisque des hommes se
battent un des hommes français des
femmes et des hommes français se battent
au mali pour nous mais pour l'ensemble
en fête de l'humanité puisque là il
s'agit de lutter contre le terrorisme
qui nous menace tous et donc il est
important de saluer quand des hommes
risquent leur vie est encore plus
malheureusement quand ils la perdent un
mot sur le texte sur lequel vous êtes
chef de file pour votre groupe les
centristes c'est le projet de loi dit de
confiance en la justice avoir un terme
qui a été jugée un peu pompeux philippe
bas ça donnait un échange un peu musclé
avec le garde des sceaux comment est ce
que vous avez vécu sous le nom de
tension dans l'hémicycle hier alors de
façon très particulière puisque j'étais
en train d'intervenir 1 quand le garde
des sceaux s'agitait pour essayer de
répondre à flic bas qu'il avait
visiblement touché enfin la discussion
générale c'est vous qui allez messieurs
qui était à la tribune donc donc voilà
de façon un peu particulier en tout cas
j'ai vu que philippe bas faisait mouche
il est vrai que philippe bas avaient
balayé à peu près tout le programme de
la justice des sujets que nous aurons à
revoir au projet de loi de finances
d'ailleurs donc je suis également co
rapporteur avec agnès canayer
mai donc voilà je pense que
notre garde des sceaux est assez réactif
voir éruptif en l'occurrence hier c'est
qu'ils se trompent pas peut-être
d'exercice lorsqu'il bataille comme ça
dans un hémicycle est ce que certains de
vos collègues peut-être te disent que il
n'a pas forcément le ton d'un ministre
d'un avocat pénaliste que c'est aussi
une théorie alors si possible je le
crois qu enfin on peut dire que
probablement en tant qu'avocat il était
totalement sincère il leur est en tant
que ministre peut-être que cet exercice
demanderai un peu plus de recul mais ça
demande du temps un autre mois sur un
autre moment de la soirée où le ton est
monté c'est sûr et bien l'extension du
secret professionnel de l'avocat aux
activités de conseil alors ce secret
professionnel ne sera pas opposable en
matière de fraude fiscale et la
corruption ça a donné un échange assez
vif y compris au sein de la majorité
entre centristes et l air qu est ce que
vous avez pensé là encore alors il y
avait une espèce d'incompréhension c'est
à dire que certains disaient qu'on
allait réduire le secret professionnel
de l'avocat or en aucun cas on le réduit
le secret professionnel de l'avocat ne
s'applique qu'aux secret de la défense
c'est à dire que quand un avocat un
client évidemment le client doit pouvoir
en toute confiance dire tout ce qu'il
sait ce qu'il a fait à son avocat sans
risquer que ce qui lui a confié puisse
aller vers la police en matière de
conseil et notamment de conseil fiscal
il n'y a pas que les avocats qui
travaillent sur le domaine des notaires
des experts comptables peuvent également
apporter des conseils qui ne sont pas
soumis au secret et pour une raison
normal c'est un conseil et là on n'est
pas en train de défendre et donc de
devoir éventuellement cacher on est en
train de conseiller ça ne peut
évidemment qu'être légal donc il n'y a
pas de raison d'appliquer le secret est
d'ailleurs ne s'applique pas aujourd'hui
la seule chose c'est que les avocats
lors de l'assemblée nationale de la
lecture à l'assemblée nationale
réussi à faire étendre un secret mais
dans ces cas là les autres professions
sont en droit d'aller demander la même
extension puisqu'ils font la même
activité
y voir plus clair et on suivra bien sûr
la suite de l'examen de ce projet doit
de confiance dans la justice et
notamment aussi
beaucoup de
44 sur public sénat merci beaucoup quand
on va tout de suite retrouvé jean mas
siégeant racontez-nous qu'est ce qui a
intéressé votre communauté et bien
écoute steve ce qui intéressait la
communauté principalement aujourd'hui
c'était la question de florence parly la
question pardon du mali on a vu une
florence parly une liste de ministres de
désarmer très vindicative très très cash
dans sa manière de répondre aux
sénateurs lorsqu'elle parlait du mali en
avec des menaces à peine voilées en leur
disant que si le gouvernement malien
avait l'intention de faire appel à des
mercenaires à des mercenaires privés
d'originaires russe d'origine russe on
n'allait pas être copains euros c'est un
peu ce qu'elle disait c'est vrai que les
internautes ont prouvé la ministre très
cash très clair pour le coup et ils ont
trouvé plus simple plutôt bien comme
type de réponse l'autre l'autre question
qui a intéressé les internautes c'était
la question de 800 bourgi le sénateur
socialiste sur la question de l'ivg et
il a reproché il a même taclé le
gouvernement lui reprochant de ne pas
mettre la question d' extension du délai
dit vg à l'ordre du jour d'ici la fin du
quinquennat c'est un enjeu
potentiellement explosive pour le
gouvernement en pleine campagne
présidentielle on le sait et on sait
aussi que le gouvernement a eu maille à
partir avec sa propre majorité à
l'assemblée nationale sur les questions
de bioéthique sur les sujets sociétaux à
la fin de vie la pma et c'est donc voilà
un angle assez intéressant et enfin un
débat qui a intéressé les internautes
sur la question qui a été posée par joël
guerriau sur les seuils pour payer par
carte bleue par carte bancaire que ce
soit en sans contact ou pas il a parlé
joël guerriau le sénateur il a parlé des
jeunes des jeunes cons pas beaucoup
d'argent et qui sont incités à acheter
soit un deuxième paquet de clopes soit
soit déçoit des jeux à gratter et ça ça
pose des problèmes pour des jeunes qui
ont pas beaucoup d'argent ça les incite
à consommer du tabac et ça crée un vrai
débat auprès d un thé au sein des
internautes voilà sur cette question de
ce qu'il faut limiter les seuils de
paiement par carte bleue est ce que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise chose
notamment pour les jeunes qui fument des
cigarettes
voilà un petit peu ce qui intéressait
les internautes dans cette séance
aujourd'hui à steve merci beaucoup jean
l'autre sujet de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement c'est cette
décision de paris de réduire le nombre
de visas accordés aux ressortissants du
maroc de l'algérie et de la tunisie je
vais vous faire réagir messieurs à ce
sujet mais tout de suite on va retrouver
patrick kanner le président du groupe
socialiste qui est avec content et qui
va en parler oui tout à fait sûr bonjour
patrick kanner président du groupe
socialiste au sénat un mot sur cette
réduction des visas avec les pays du
maghreb le ministre darmanin a répondu à
une question sur ce sujet lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement il
a dit le jour où ces pays reviendront à
des relations normales de laisser passer
consulaire et d'un brevet dans une
relation normale avec ces pays que
pensez-vous de la réponse de gérald
darmanin c'est un nouveau constat
d'échec pour la diplomatie française
c'est à dire des pays amis qui
finalement refus de collaborer avec la
france sur la mise en oeuvre de ce qu'on
appelle les occulter f les ordonnances
de quitter le territoire français montre
bien la faiblesse finalement de la
parole de la france vis-à-vis de ces
soi-disant partenaires donc la réponse
française d'une réponse voilà agressive
mais qui surtout soulève l'inca passé de
la france à pouvoir faire vivre le droit
français dans ces pays deuxième sujet
que je voulais évoquer avec vous car
vous êtes membre de la commission des
lois ici au sénat le 13 octobre prochain
projet doit être présenté en conseil des
ministres et gabriela talent a annoncé
qu'ils allaient proposer dans ce projet
doit de maintenir jusqu'à l'été la
possibilité de recourir au pass
sanitaires à quelle est votre réaction
un pis-aller une fuite en avant une
incapacité finalement d'aller jusqu'au
bout de la démarche le gouvernement à
juste titre veut que tous les français
soient vaccinés eh bien il reporte cette
échéance de mois en mois y compris en
enjambant les élections présidentielles
c'est quand même et législatives qui
auraient suggéré
et on pourrait voilà comme ça à
prolonger d'une durée nous dirons non et
je crois de manière unanime en tout cas
en grande partie au sénat nous estime en
fait que c'est une mauvaise solution que
la vraie solution c'est celle que nous
proposons la vaccination obligatoire le
13 octobre pour aller vite et une mesure
égalitaire c'est un constat d'échec que
ce report du pass sanitaire il faut le
dire clairement français un dernier mot
de politique si vous le voulez bien qu'à
vous êtes proche d'anne hidalgo dans la
campagne qui s'ouvre pour l'élection
présidentielle que penser de la
candidature de yannick jadot qui
maintenant est bien et le candidat et
des écologistes est ce que ça peut faire
de l'ombre à la candidature de mme lago
qui est en difficulté on peut le dire
dans les sondages coûté un algo est en
campagne en campagne au rythme qui est
le sien elle maîtrise son temps c'est à
dire c'est un rythme dans les
territoires un rythme sur des idéaux
aujourd'hui elle est au congrès de
bordeaux des hlm pour présenter des
idées sur le logement donc donnons du
temps au temps pour reprendre une
expression célèbre jeu jadot va rentrer
en campagne il a fait 51 % il a gagné
mais il devra tenir compte aussi des
mesures très lourde très forte très
extrémiste pour certaines de madame
rousseau nous verrons bien le moment
venu pour l'instant chacun est dans son
couloir et doit convaincre un maximum de
français c'est la dynamique et dans le
sens de yannick jadot ça pourrait être
un ralliement possible en janvier eh
bien le sera dans le sens d aller
d'algos voilà ma réponse
d'avoir répondu aux micros de public
sénat aujourd'hui merci beaucoup quentin
pour selim fairview en direct la
réduction du nombre de visas accordés
aux ressortissants des pays du maghreb
françois patriat c'est un constat
d'échec pour la diplomatie française
comme le dit à patrick nerfs d'abord je
suis toujours un peu supris joue à
patrick kanner chaque semaine après les
questions intervenir
jamais je ne le vois c'est le une mesure
je le veux critiquer systématiquement il
est mal à l'aise dès qu'il s'agit de
parler de son propre camp critiquent
aujourd'hui son pays qui critiquent la
france toute mesure toute mesure prise
par le gouvernement ne trouve pas grâce
à ses yeux aucune jolie entendu
critiquer la pole à la crise sanitaire
j'ai entendu critiquer toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises aujourd'hui
ça lui même pas ok mais sur le fond je
dirais que c'est comme la démarche de
patrick a l'air qu'il oublie qu'il a été
ministre qui aujourd'hui est un opposant
systématique qui grincent permanence
mais qu'elle ne propose rien donc de
quoi hurler dorilas là dessus sur ces
sujets imaginer d'en regarder la
position de la france aujourd'hui nous
décidons de prendre des mesures de
rétorsion si nous ne le faisons pas on
nous le reprochera l'extrême droite la
gauche va dire vous pourrez
aussi je dis si nous ne le faisons pas
on nous reprochait de ne pas le faire et
si on le fait on dit que sa démagogie
pour courir après l'extrême droite et
vous le dis la france est pour une
mesure juste elle discute avec des pays
partenaires hélas aujourd'hui à faire
entendre sa voix elle constate que les
pays partenaires avec qui nous
travaillons tous les jours ne
remplissent pas leurs devoirs et
n'oubliez une domaine europe répondent
pas aux demandes qui leur sont faites
elle en tire les conséquences et elle
prend des mesures à même je crois que
c'est des mesures de sagesse c'est des
mesures d'efficacité les critiquer
systématiquement parce que c'est le
gouvernement qu'on était ce qui le fait
ça me paraît aujourd'hui dérisoire jean
françois rapin c'est une mesure juste
comme le dit françois patriat
nécessaire non je pense que comprend on
prend le sujet là par le petit bout de
la lorgnette vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'il ya en discussion au niveau
européen le pacte asile immigration
qui est un volet qui est un volet
extrêmement élargie de la façon dont
l'europe et ses états membres pourrait
gérer la question migratoire qui devient
vraiment une calamité même si on doit
être très sensibles aux sujets humains
qui sont portées par cette
là aujourd'hui on est et s'assigne
s'assigne déjà je pense parce que il y
avait une volonté assez affirmée en
montrant les pectoraux de la france en
dix ans nous règlerons ces problèmes et
le pacte asile immigration pendant la
présidence française sera abouti sauf
que aujourd'hui on voit que ça n'est pas
le cas l'avancée des négociations est
très complexe et donc la stratégie
française c'est peut-être de repartir
pas à pas sur des mesurettes qui
permettrait de lutter progressivement
contre l'immigration je ne suis pas
devin je ne sais pas ce que ce genre de
mesures pour en donner à terme néanmoins
ce que je sais c'est que auront en armes
en prenant ces petites mesures
finalement on risque de ne pas aboutir
sur 7,2 cette vision élargie du pack
tats-unis mer et immigration je rappelle
qu'il y a aujourd'hui pas seulement la
route du sud pour la migration mais
aujourd'hui on crée une route à l'est
regardez les problèmes la lituanie en
particulier avec la biélorussie on a le
problème migratoire calaisien avec ma
traversée de la manche donc il ya je
pense que c'est un problème vraiment
énergie et là on est sur un tout petit
mais je reconnais c'est la france doit
rien faire j'ai pris ça
va
parler tout de suite retrouvé elisabeth
moreno la ministre la secrétaire d'état
en charge de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes pourquoi et bien parce que
la pma pour tout entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui quand on veut
vous êtes moreno bonjour et ministre est
délégué en charge de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité et
d'égalité des chances un mot sur ce
décret est enfin paru j'avais envie de
dire qui permet la paix main à toutes
les femmes vont être réduits sur twitter
qu'est-ce que j'en avais voilà comment
ce que vous avez vécu cette publication
mais avec beaucoup de soin comme
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes qui
attendaient la possibilité d'avoir accès
à la pma si je crois que c'est un acte
de justice extrêmement important un acte
d'égalité entre toutes les femmes de
notre pays qu'elle soit lesbienne
qu'elles soient hétérosexuels qu'elles
soient célibataires et donc comme elle
je me réjouis que ce décret soit enfin
paru et qu'elles puissent commencer leur
projet parental c'était un engagement
fort du président de la république et on
est tous heureux de le voir enfin
arriver à terme ou dit qu'elle puisse
enfin commencer à leur projet c'est la
question clé maintenant quand est ce que
les premières permanent pouvoir avoir
lieu en france est ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'elles peuvent maintenant
d'immédiatement commencé leur projet
elles peuvent immédiatement se rendre
dans les cecos elles peuvent
immédiatement rencontré leur médecin et
commencer à construire ce projet je sais
que certaines d'entre elles ont commencé
déjà se renseigner il y a deux ans quand
les discussions au sujet de cette loi
bioéthique ont commencé donc je peux
vous dire quel nom nous ont pas attendus
j'ai rencontré avec olivier ferrand et
adrien taquet certaines familles la
semaine dernière et elle était très très
très pressé de voir le décret sorti hier
qu'est ce qui peut encore bloqué le fait
que 0 cours à 7pm masquer des choses
dans la loi sur les donneurs de sperme
qui sont encore en cours alors je sais
qu'il y à une inquiétude à la fois sur
le délai est sûre le temps de deux mise
en oeuvre de ces projets et je peux vous
dire qu'olivier ferrand a été
extrêmement sensible à cette
problématique il a décidé d'investir 8
millions d'euros tant en ressources
humaines quand moyen d'équipements pour
permettre en fait au plus grand nombre
de femmes de pouvoir avoir accès à cette
pma et comme lui je forme le voeu de
voir la première grossesse pma d'ici la
fin de notre quinquennat un dernier mot
peut-être sur cette réforme ce sera la
seule véritablement sociétal ce que vous
regrettez d'avoir pu être investis sur
d'autres sujets ça a été une période
extrêmement compliqué ce qui était
important c'est que nous sortions de
cette crise sanitaire par le haut nous
ne sommes pas encore complètement sortis
mais nous sommes dans la bonne direction
c'est est que nous maintenions à flot
notre économie et le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que c'est le cas
puisque l'épreuve les prévisions de
croissance sont vraiment très très très
positive donc j'ai presque envie de dire
chaque chose en son temps mais cette
progression sociétale et d'envergure
elle est importante et je suis très
heureuse qu'elle puisse bénéficier à
toutes les femmes de notre pays il nous
reste moins de 30 secondes mais parlons
rapidement du texte sur les terrains
pied de conversion l'interdiction de ces
thérapies de conversion on sait que
c'est un texte porté par la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale l'a encore un
commentaire eh bien je ne peux que me
réjouir qu'une très grande majorité ce
matin en commission les est votée et que
on rentre dans le processus de
discussion de cette loi je sais que
beaucoup de personnes l'attendaient que
beaucoup de jeunes ont souffert de ces
soi-disant thérapie de conversion parce
que je veux rappeler qu'il n'ya rien à
guérir dans l'homosexualité et là aussi
c'est un grand jour pour nous et pour
notre ministère merci merci il est
maintenant devenu commenter tous ces
sujets au micro de public sénat merci à
vous merci beaucoup quentin la pma pour
tout françois patriat
seule mesure
sociétal du quinquennat annoncé par la
banque dans le truc un peu pris beaucoup
de mesures sociétaires pour les enfants
le poids deux mesures aujourd'hui pour
aujourd'hui pour la psychiatrie chaque
jour chaque semaine le gouvernement
annonce des mesures qui vont dans le
sens du changement du quotidien pour la
santé des français alors celle là bien
sûr on peut la laque et métiers sur
cette finale s'est passé aussi des mines
et solidaire est vous vous saluer vous
cette mesure aux pma pour tout ce qui
entre en vigueur aujourd'hui je la salue
passer un bon prince le gouvernement
c'est un combat que nous menions dans
les débats au sénat nous avons été sur
la maman ou leur donne que le
gouvernement face à ce qu'ils soient
c'est vrai et ça vient d'ailleurs
démentir ce crédit de
deux faux tout la leur françois patriat
à propos du groupe socialiste et de son
président on salue qu'on sait bien ce
qu'on regrette c'est que c'est très rare
mais je sois bien remuer pour venir à
cette mesure
sur les visas
le gros problème c'est que il ya une
négociation diplomatique on connaît les
sanctions et les pressions qu'on peut
exercer sur des partenaires quand ils ne
veulent pas jouer le jeu on peut y
compris rappeler l'ambassadeur on peut
s'en prendre aux passeports
diplomatiques à plein il ya une palette
d'accord mais là qui on frappe avec ça
et c'est toujours les façons à un
étudiant méritant qui veut étudier s'il
va pas avoir de visa parce que son
gouvernement n'a pas été disons
le loyal dans une négociation et
français ont sanctionné les oies
gouvernance et pas n'importe quoi y'a eu
faut maintenant je vais vous donner les
chiffres
est il resté très évasif quand je veux
le dire parce que c'est très
démonstrative le trou grâce est très
démocratique que ce que fait le
gouvernement traîne il court après le
mind pèse parce que puisqu'il me dit les
visas gogo c'est pas le sujet des bises
à gogo non il n'y a pas de sujet de visa
govou je vais vous donner le chiffre en
2021 on a délivré 18 1579 visa sur
vingt-quatre mille demandes et la
pandémie en 2019 c'était
346 milles sur quel sale affaire de
berne et de battes et audiences étaient
ceux
de l'année dernière
déjà
donc c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet c
est ce qu on fait une restriction pour
sanctionner un gouvernement qui ne veut
pas jouer le jeu dans l'étude hier
en sanctionnant des gens qui sont déjà
dans la difficulté qui met qui ont comme
les étudiants étrangers par exemple qui
attend qu'ils construisent un projet
pour étudier c'était pour l'art dit
est-ce que dia plus que ça vise les
essais non mais continuer à alimenter ce
climax et les visas globaux et cetera
même quand c'est faux même qu'on s'est
avéré que c'est faux parce que vous
alimenter les peurs sur lesquels
prospèrent les veaux national non
partisan et l'immigration et rayonner
vous avez raison des
débuté et elle se poursuit donc sur ce
plateau merci merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté de répondre à mes
questions merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau tout de suite vous avez rendez
vous avec adrien taquet pourquoi a déjà
attaqué le secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'enfance et des familles était
auditionné cet après-midi par la
commission des affaires sociales à
l'ordre du jour la protection de
l'enfance un texte a été adopté à
l'assemblée nationale au mois de juillet
c'est maintenant au sénat et au sénateur
d'avoir leur mot à dire regardez cette
audition normale juste après